[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
good morning and welcome to the midas
media networks
coverage of the january 6 select
committee public hearings day number
four welcome welcome to all those who
are joining us out there we have a great
panel for you the hour before the gavel
comes down the gavel will come down in
just just in an hour uh in washington
where we will watch the january 6 select
committee
have two panels of witnesses today on
the first panel we have the arizona
house speaker the georgia secretary of
state also his chief operating officer
and then in the second panel we will
hear from another
georgian an election worker from georgia
as well
um we are going to bring you some great
coverage here in the first hour also if
we have a break today which i would
imagine
of seeing the past where they have a
break in between the two panels we will
have some commentary in between so stick
around for the commentary at the break
we will also have great panel commentary
after
the hearings to give our insight into
what has happened um today is
likely to be a bombshell day there's
been some bombshell news this morning
not only about the committee um
the the select committee hearing today
about these uh official states uh state
officials but also we hear that we may
we may have documentary footage
of donald trump his family mike pence
possibly
um
conspiring to overthrow the government
of the united states i'm not sure
exactly what's in this documentary film
it has been subpoenaed and apparently
the the documentary film maker i believe
his last name is holder that has been uh
subpoenaed by congress and i just seen
the statement from just uh about an hour
ago
and it looks like they're going to
they plan on complying
with that subpoena in court
um so i i without further ado i want to
bring on a legal expert here
karen agnivolo from legal af uh karen
how are you this morning
hi can you hear me i can i can hear you
great i can hear you great um i i was i
was supposed to have your co-host popock
but he's he's not quite with us yet here
so i'm gonna i'm gonna bring you on
um but let me ask you karen what do you
make of
uh not only the panel today because i
think the panel is important uh here i
have the january six
committee's official tweet from
yesterday we have rusty bowers the
arizona house speaker brad rathersberger
um the georgia secretary of st state
gabriel sterling his state chief
operating officer of the secretary of
state's office and then in panel two
uh we have shea moss
uh former georgia election worker what
do you make of some of these this
witness panel
really what kind of implications that
maybe some of this testimony may mean
in a criminal setting because some are
surmising you may be one of them that
um donald trump's greatest criminal
exposure here and maybe the fastest uh
way to um
an indictment would be in georgia for
some of the 11 800 some odd votes that
he wanted yeah so
um so you know the january 6 select
committee has been very interesting and
how they've decided to
uh present testimony and present
evidence right this isn't just a hearing
where they're just kind of calling
different people and seeing who shows up
it's clear that they're doing this in
kind of
presentable buckets of information so
for example the last one was very much
about kind of what happened to pence
right and all about
mike pence on january 6. and this next
tranche really is
kind of what did donald trump and his
kind of
co-writers if you will or
co-conspirators what what what did they
do vis-a-vis the um the states and in
two states in particular both arizona
and
georgia we are going to learn today kind
of what was done
and
why it is that they face criminal
exposure it's very clear to me that
these hearings are a road map to the
various prosecutors uh sort of a
spoon-feeding road map of
this is what all the evidence is that's
out there this is what it shows and
these are the crimes and the exposure to
which
you could potentially prosecute them for
now understandably the um it's a little
confusing for i think um
for people because you you see these you
watch these hearings and you see these
videos and you you hear the testimony
and you're like what are they waiting
for what's going on
um
but obviously this is not a trial and
it's a different standard it's a
different burden of proof you know at
any sort of criminal
prosecution they're going to have to
prove each and every element of every
crime beyond a reasonable doubt that's
the highest standard that every single
criminal prosecution must face
and so that's sort of what i think
prosecutors are watching this
kind of looking at to see what evidence
is there is it admissible evidence so
for example hearsay is not admissible
right it has to be direct evidence it
has to be admissible evidence and um and
does it prove beyond a reasonable doubt
that donald trump
committed a crime or crimes and
there's been a lot of
kind of
opinions out there about various crimes
that he could be prosecuted for and what
the legal standards are i've been
listening to a lot of commentators say
that he has to show that what he knew
what he was doing was wrong
um that it was not criminal that he had
criminal intent
when he did these things that he that he
actually thought that he knew that he
lost the election
um and that he wasn't uh had really no
kind of legitimate
uh path forward and that would give him
either the the sort of criminal intent
mindset necessary to prosecute him um so
we'll see we'll see if they can make
that out i'm not entirely sure you need
that i think i think for example on on
january 6
when he
basically called you know by the time
january 6 came around
so many people he'd lost so many court
cases saying there was no election fraud
he had so many people tell him there was
no path forward here yet he summoned all
these people to the capitol
he sort of it's almost like he brought
the gun to the capitol he loaded the gun
and he pointed it at
at the capitol and that's what these
people were right he sort of he sort of
brought them there he loaded them up
with his words and his you know sort of
all the things that he said and then he
literally pointed them at the capitol
you know he revved them up and and sort
of pointed them at the capitol and and
shot you know took his shot and they
went there and if i were the k if i were
the prosecutor in this case
i would painstakingly uh put together
a very detailed roadmap for the jury of
those 187 minutes from the time they
breached the capital to the time that
donald trump finally tweeted and said
whatever he said to get them to you know
to stop i don't even remember what he
said but finally we finally heard from
him during those 187 minutes who called
him what did they say to him you know
pictures videos phone calls maybe this
is maybe this documentary filmmaker will
have some of that footage whatever it is
put together those 187 minutes and what
you will see i i guarantee what you will
see is that he knew
that these people went there what they
were doing that it was violent that they
had a noose that they said hey mike
pence they were trying to get into uh
the various rooms in the capitol to try
and do terrible things that that they
were fighting that police officers were
getting injured ultimately losing some
of them lost their life you will see
that he knew
and he did not stop it at that point and
you know frankly he had a duty to stop
it at that point so i think if you if
you do that i think you've got him for
um seditious conspiracy i think in
georgia what you'll see today you'll
you'll get the evidence of the phone
call that's thankfully it's recorded and
it's taped and you're going to see that
he uh he called and said find the
you know one more vote than the number
he lost by i mean he was absolutely
trying to interfere with the election
very transparent very transparent in his
intent there wasn't he i actually i want
to bring in michael popock if he if he's
ready i want to bring in your co-host uh
why not have the uh the legal af staff
here on together michael how are you
karen
tony
what do you make of all this because
here is um
uh mindy hassan's tweet he says in the
past 72 hours the ex-gop president has
promised to pardon insurrectionists if
re-elected a gop senate candidate has
incited violence in a campaign ad
referring to eric greitens in missouri
the and the largest state gop party has
rejected biden's election victory he's
referring to the texas gop convention
it's an extremist group now not a normal
party so what what does maybe that even
mean for today because that has to that
has to play into this somehow is because
we we we saw in 2020 when
brad rathersberger and more gabriel
sterling his chief uh operating officer
came out and gave that very very very
passionate now press conference saying
you're gonna get someone killed and he
was talking to the president of the
united states because they were
threatening their lives and we see that
the gop is just absolutely
hellbent on not admitting the truth so
what kind of truth do you think we'll
find out today that they'll totally
reject michael brown well as thanks tony
as karen and i said in an earlier pod
today we were evaluating what today
fourth day of jan 6 is going to be about
i said if day three was the hang mike
pence day day four is all about arizona
and georgia with a sprinkling of ginny
thomas and i think that's going to make
for a powerful must-watch tv on the
georgia side we've got live testimony or
if somebody has a baby by tape
of brad raffensberger the newly
re-elected secretary of state for
georgia and his coo um gabe sterling who
gave that passionate speech that you
talked about aimed at donald trump and
his supporters when he said you're going
to get people killed
and they're going to testify today about
not only the phone call that trump made
but the earlier phone call that we've
forgotten about that was done in
november on november 13th by lindsey
graham
he was the advanced team for donald
trump he made the first phone call to
brafensberger and election officials and
election investigators telling them to
basically throw out legally cast ballots
republicans like to say cast all ballots
what they really mean is uh or count all
ballots they really mean count all
republican ballots they don't really
care about the rest
so you got the lindsey graham phone call
that's going to come front and center
today i believe on november the 13th
followed by the january second phone
call that trump himself actually made
which i came in a little bit late i'm
not sure karen touched on this or not
that is really the the number one piece
of evidence against donald trump
is sitting with the fulton county
prosecutor fanny willis because he
actually made a phone call recorded by
raffensberger and by sterling in which
he not only said that now infamous can
you just find me 11 780 votes between
friends
but he also went on to say if you don't
do that here's the threat here's the
extortion
you don't do that you're committing a
crime you better get criminal defense
lawyers
while he was doing that meadows which
i'm sure we'll hear about today was
making phone calls to
the chief georgia you know election
investigator about trying to find fraud
find it for me so you've got the three
the this is the three on three
basketball game right meadows
lindsey graham donald trump all working
between november and january so that's
going to be georgia day then we have
this very famous or soon to be famous
election worker
um
uh whose last name is moss she actually
sued successfully and settled with the
one america network which is like
newsmax because they showed a video of
her and other election workers
legitimately moving ballots from table
to table which by the way if you've ever
gone to watch counting like i have
that's how it happens you have to
physically move boxes and they accused
her on video of doing something
underhanded and either bringing in
ballots for biden or discarding ballots
that were republican and she sued for
defamation
and she recovered in a settlement that's
public
so she's testifying today about what she
did in the vote counting room in georgia
and the attacks on her and then they're
going to have in arizona this is the
jenny thomas connection which i think is
going to not blow people's minds to
follow legal aaf and the tony michael
show but are going to blow everybody
else's mind is that these the ch the
speaker of the house
in arizona a republican another rusty
rusty bowers rusty bowers continuing the
trend of only having people with r next
to their name testifying the gen 6
committee he's going to testify today
that ginny thomas reached out to him
particularly to try to push the fake
elector scandal uh stratagem in arizona
and he's gonna give compelling testimony
related to that so we've got georgia
arizona day but as we've learned already
after three days tony just because they
announced who their witnesses are in the
first session and second session it
doesn't account for all of the other
video clips and documentary evidence
that they're going to pull together to
supplement these live witnesses um today
and i think karen did a great job of
talking about why the building the case
for prosecutors
who have the harder job than the gen sex
committee let's let's call it like it is
higher standard of proof beyond a
reasonable doubt
the quality of evidence has to be of a
higher grade if you will at the criminal
prosecution level then even at the jan
six level usually you need witnesses
with first-hand knowledge not hearsay or
double hearsay or triple hearsay you
need um you know physical evidence
maybe not the fingerprints of the person
on them but pretty darn close to it as
you build your case it's a different
build than what john 6. doesn't mean
that karen's not right that the road map
is being presented right for prosecutors
everywhere to follow including the
department of justice and merrick
garland well i appreciate you joining us
michael and breaking down the the
witnesses and thank you karen she had to
jump for a second uh karen will be on
and off today hopefully she can join us
during the break or after um but
thank you michael for for giving us your
insight into the guest stick around if
you can i know i think you're you're
you're off to somewhere so maybe maybe
we'll catch you on thursday how's that
yeah if you want me for another couple
of minutes i can stay but if you want to
i i gotta i'm gonna move on to michael
cohen because i got a video that i want
to show uh michael cohen here um so
stick around
michael cohen if you're ready there um
michael how are you how are you how good
how are you oh i'm doing great i i
actually you know because we've talked
several times before these committee
hearings
because you kind of know the mindset of
donald trump
and you know how he operates
you know
and you actually did a video the other
day
about this
this mob decoding kind of thing because
a lot of people think that his language
is childish but it's it's simple
language so people understand it i think
is kind of what i got from your video
mostly but i have a clip here that i
want to show you and it's actually of
yesterday from eric boland's show on
newsmax where donald trump is asked the
question
if he is scared of criminal charges let
me play that and get your reaction on
the other side of it be a shame
are you concerned that that there may be
some sort of criminal investigation from
the doj well we did nothing wrong other
than complain about the election and
i've been complaining about it from day
one and even texas just came out i don't
know if you saw that but texas just came
out
and they are they were very strong the
republican party in texas you saw what
that's actually put in their platform
that they don't accept it they don't
accept it no
so michael we see there he's looking for
any straw and i think that's been the
you know
he said he's been complaining a long
time and he's complained a long time but
i think that's what we're going to see
with georgia today with some of this
evidence that he was grasping at a straw
anyone to say that there was fraud you
notice there in that clip he went
straight to the texas republican party
where they put that in their platform
they voted for it and he he he draw that
straw immediately right he's like oh
here's someone who will say that it was
stolen and it's official you know yeah
tony look let me be very clear about
this if there was a dog that barked out
that donald trump had won the election
he would then talk about the dog right
um and whether or not that that dog was
actually speaking so that humans can
understand it or it's only that donald
can understand it if it benefits donald
that's what he's going to talk about but
remember something he set this up long
before the election he set it up months
in advance that if he lost the election
okay if he lost the election the only
way that he could possibly lose is if in
fact it was stolen from him so he set
the stolen theory up well in advance of
that november election date and one of
the things that donald does very very
well is he covers his ass now this is
something where i saw that you had put
up previously with um your other guests
um michael and karen
some medy hassan quote and listen matty
doesn't know what he's babbling about
here so let me be very clear about this
where trump turns around and claims that
he will pardon these insurrectionists he
will pardon people that he believes are
being unfairly treated all right that's
not illegal it's stupid but it's not
illegal and what is he doing he's
playing to his base so we as we'll call
a sane america we have to ignore the
stupidity of what comes out of trump's
mouth and the only way that we're going
to get rid of donald now because
everybody wants to see you know donald
and orange we want to see you know
ivanka jared don jr kimberly gargoyle we
want to see lara and dopey eric we want
to see them all rudy kaluti drunk and
giuliani we want them all in orange
because that will make us feel better
it's no different why i ended up going
because it made the country feel better
that's not what we need to do we need to
get together whether it's through midas
through legal af whether it's to uh you
know maya culpa join a movement that
will help in order to ensure that not
just the midterm elections go democrat
but also the general election and what
we're seeing as a result of a lot of
people like myself who come out and
speak truth to power
one of the things that we're seeing 60
of americans want to see donald trump
held accountable for the january sixth
insurrection and that's a great number
but if we're going to rest upon that i
think we're going to be very
disappointed in the upcoming um midterm
as well as in the general election
well i i think i think you're getting at
something there michael when you talk
about uh holding him accountable because
as karen and popock talk today there may
be there may be some visibility of
accountability today of what it may look
like right like a prelude to what could
happen with the grand jury that is
happening in georgia with this testimony
today um and and your and you also
mentioned you know any straw that you
would that he would grasp at so what do
you think do you do you think because it
seems like brad rathburger is not there
uh only they're under subpoena so what
do you think we're gonna hear from brad
rathersberger the secretary of state
about the tape that he taped and he
released
first of all we're not going to hear
anything different than what everybody
has already heard ad nauseum over the
course of the past six plus months since
that recording first came out you're
going to hear them basically dissecting
each and every line that came out and
what again this is where both karen and
michael are spot on this is not an easy
case for prosecutors because trump who's
ignorant will just claim that's not what
i meant that this is an it was an
ignorant statement okay i'll acknowledge
that but it's not an illegal statement
now are there things that he has done
that are illegal sure um you know
obstruction of um an official proceeding
that's certainly one of them or the
other meaning conspiracy to defraud the
united states yes but then again we
still get to the burden
my feeling is you know there are so many
things that trump can
be held uh legally accountable including
what just took place here at the
district attorney with alvin bregwin he
walked away from a case you have
financial crimes these are easier within
which to prove we have the attorney
general here in new york that's going
after trump civilly that's a much lower
bar i mean we need to
look
it's is do i think that these hearings
are extremely important the answer is
yes they are extremely they set a
historical record but i have a funny
feeling merrick garland is more
concerned about you know the jack
goldsmith actually had it really um did
a very very good job
in this new york times article that came
out about the three big decisions that
merrick garland has to make uh in terms
of the prosecution of trump and i
certainly i recommend everybody to read
it because it's absolutely true and you
know with the biggest one being in my
opinion the third one which is whether
um you know national interest will be
served by prosecuting trump and again my
feeling is yes but then again if in fact
that he wins
and it's going to be in my opinion very
difficult to get 12 people onto a jury
um
to not have one of them who is a trump
loyalist and so that person could
certainly be the block uh you know in
terms of a jury coming back with a
guilty finding and look i just think
it's going to be a very difficult case
not that it's not important not that it
shouldn't be done
it's just that it's going to be
difficult and i think merrick garland
has to stop thinking about whether or
not you win or lose but rather not
the presenting of the evidence to the
american people and we're entitled to
know what what they know that's my
feeling
well i think you're right in that
bringing a case against donald trump
isn't just as easy as slam dunking
putting him in in an orange jumpsuit as
you put it earlier um because the
ramifications of him winning a criminal
prosecution could be
um maybe even a more dire outcome for
our country thank you michael for
joining us um i appreciate you giving us
your commentary each hearing here
on the midas media network um stick
around if you can if you if you got time
after the hearing we'd love to hear from
you if not we'd love to hear from you on
thursday thank you michael for joining
us thank you tony thank you
uh i'm gonna bring in jessica denton she
knows something about battling trump in
the courtroom she is the trump nba
killer now we we talked to jessica last
week but i have some pointed questions
that i'd like to ask her uh about brand
rather burger
jessica welcome welcome to the show how
are you
doing well tony how are you doing this
morning i'm doing fantastic um you know
we see that we have the georgia
secretary of state brad rathersberger
and i was really thinking especially
some conversations that we had had about
um you know the gop because you were a
member of the trump team um you know
some people know that you left the trump
team you actually beat him in court
you're one of the only ones to beat in
the court uh and and i believe the only
one with the nda um that he that he has
on people
but my thought was is that brad
rathersberger you know if you go back
and you watch the press conference of
his chief operating officer who we're
also going to hear from today uh gabriel
sterling he gave a loud cry into a
microphone to the gop and the president
not not democrats not really liberals um
he was crying out for the republican
party to really
say hey unequivocally this election was
not stolen um but brad rathersberger
even
he there's been times where he's been on
the news he said he would not appear
even under subpoena we know he's he's
supposed to appear today under subpoena
but he's also said that he may or may
not even vote for trump in 2024. i have
that clip let me show you that clip and
see what your reaction is on the other
side but i'll ask it one more time can
you say emphatically tonight that you
will not vote in 2024 for the man who
you say threatened you in sighted
threats against you
i believe in 2024 we'll have a person
that can grow the party because we
didn't have 50 percent of the popular
popular vote for a long period of time
we need to grow our party we need to
figure out how to do that so we have an
attractive message that actually
embraces people expands the base and we
can make sure that we win the 50 plus
one percent of the people plus win the
electoral college
now we see there that he was uh he was
really pressured hard and that's the
very end uh before he let him go but
what do you what do you make of
the republican party the gop
in general right now because again we
see
we see eric greitens threatening the gop
inside their party we have the texas gop
doing what seems to be
very un
uh
how do i want to say welcoming ways with
the platform that they voted what do you
make of all this
well it's equivocation right i mean
where is this man was threatened his
life was threatened his
deputy his chief operating officer
gabrielle sterling came out and pled
for other leaders to come forward and
make sure that these people were not
literally killed because of the rhetoric
that trump was spewing the lies that he
was viewing and yet a year later
promoting a book called i believe his
book was called integrity counts
[Laughter]
as equivocation on the question
the answer to every one of these
individuals who has at some point taken
a moral stand against trump but still
maintains that r next to their name the
question should be an unqualified
absolutely no i will not support donald
trump and you know i think brad
raffensberger is a christian i'm a
christian i'm just wondering if they're
reading the same book that i am because
this book says you cannot serve two
masters either you will hate the one and
love the other or you will cleave to the
one and despise the other so if you've
taken that moral stand and you've
decided you are going to serve god my
understanding of god is truth if you're
going to serve principle if you're going
to serve justice and integrity then you
cannot still bow down at the altar of
your career at the altar of the
republican party at the altar of donald
j trump and that is by that is drawing a
clear line there should be absolutely no
equivocation whatsoever so while i
definitely applaud rothensberger for
what he did in
the days and months
after the election and gabrielle
sterling for his very clear words these
men these republicans should have no
equivocation whatsoever and you talked
about this violence um this is i mean
this is getting really out of control
and notice notice the flagrance with
which
republican allies of donald trump are
threatening violence against their
fellow republicans i mean it is a very
bold flagrant
threat
these are the consequences of impunity
this is what happens when we have a year
and a half later zero consequences for
the brute force
the sheer
lies that donald trump propagated onto
this country and there's been zero
accountability so going back to what
michael was talking about is a
prosecution hard is a conviction hard
maybe so but we have the evidence we
must move forward with it you better
believe that when i went forward to
challenge trump's nba in court i thought
it would be darn hard i thought it would
be
i had a million reasons of
why i should not bring this forward and
what the possible negative ramifications
on my life personally would be
if i did this but i simply acted on the
right idea i did not waver from it and
that
that
trust that faith in the truth was like a
shield and a propellant to me and it and
it brought me to victory as you said
being the first and only one to
invalidate this nda in a court of law
well i i think i think that gives it
gives hope to um folks out there that
and justice can be brought to trump even
even in the form of invalidating
a
uh
an nda
back to rather sperger and um his chief
operating officer because we're also
going to hear from the arizona house
speaker
speaking of
wobbling we see
maybe jeannie thomas had been talking to
rusty bowers and rusty bowers had some
pushback you know we we see this
in the moment of of after the election
in january 6 and even mitch mcconnell
and kevin mccarthy gave some pushback
but as soon as the country gave them
leeway and the trump supporters and the
republican party gave him leeway
they snapped back to supporting trump um
in that moment and we've seen the texas
gop just
be all in with this new platform um for
trump and you mentioned eric greitens
doing the kicking down the door and
killing
um members of his own party it seems to
be he's threatening them in that video
that's what it seemed like to me
what what do you make of even the
arizona house speaker coming uh to
testify
these these are not testifying against
democrats there it is going to be a
republican house speaker testifying
against clarence thomas wife jeannie
thomas possibly i think that's what
we're going to hear is that she was
pressure there was pressure coming
from her even and the trump camp i think
we're gonna see that too
tell us about the pressure that the
trump camp puts on because you probably
experienced this with your with the nda
so tell us about that pressure and what
do you expect rusty bowers and even the
secretary of state and his chief
operating officer and the election
official in georgia to say about that
pressure because you've experienced it
yeah um well i think the pressure um
is
is what is governing the republican
party today it is why they have not
distanced themselves as a body from
donald trump and we hear all these
murmurings all the time from
reporters who speak to these people on
background or off the record
and they are always it's always the same
story we know that donald trump is
dangerous we know that his uh he's
inciting extremism and violence but
we're afraid for our families we're
afraid for our lives
um
as i said before this is this is the the
problem with impunity for these kind of
actions they have to be confronted
another thing in this book a lot of
republicans
claim to be christians okay
and this book if you're reading the same
thing i i am
talks about christian armor and you know
what it says about christian armor it
says that it says that we we have the
breastplate of righteousness the helmet
of salvation the sword of the spirit
that that's the kind of protection
if we are people of faith
that we
that we trust in that we trust to
protect us when we are going against
evil forces in the world but we are
standing on the side of right and here's
the problem with today's republican
party today we're going to have a few
exceptions we're going to have rusty
bowers who i think is going to speak
with clarity about the threats that he
encountered and the pushback that he
offered i think gabriel sterling is
going to speak with absolute clarity and
raffensberger while maybe reluctantly i
think is going to speak the truth
the other republicans should take a cue
from these people and act with some
courage act with some moral clarity and
integrity and stop bowing down at the
altar of donald trump and fearing evil
and instead be like david
be like the prophets who who who put on
that christian armor
and defeated the evil now here's the
problem i'm going back to what michael
cohen said this republican party has
demonstrated time and time again that
they are not willing to do that and that
is why they are a dangerous party they
are a faithless party we absolutely
cannot allow these individuals who claim
to adhere to this sacred text
blaspheme the meaning of freedom and and
the the foundations of democracy that we
have by not having the spine and the
moral courage that is required of them
in this moment when their base
their base the ones that look to them as
leaders
are being lied to constantly these
people are not fit for power and we
cannot allow them to to govern either
house of congress or god forbid a trump
replica in the white house again we have
our work cut out for us
i completely agree with you and i think
i think hopefully we will see the
testimony uh come to bear today of the
pressure that was put on them not just
by trump allies but possibly trump
himself i know there's a tape of it
that rather burger had taped even he
knew in that moment that he should
record
what the president of the united states
at the time donald trump was saying
because he knew it possibly would be
evidence thank you jessica for joining
us if you can stick around for the break
and
some after show commentary uh once we
hear from the witnesses today i
appreciate you joining us to talk to you
soon jessica thank you
so i i want to bring in
one of the midas mighty's favorites
texas paul
to see what he thinks about the
witnesses that are going to
come in today
texas paul how are you sir
man i am wonderful i am wonderful i
think the witnesses are going to be
fantastic i mean raffensberger is going
to lay this down in his own words we are
going to see i
uh we are going to see things that we
have not heard before
i am very much looking forward to this
video
uh but i want to address a couple things
one
the you know i'm i'm following the chat
as we go along yeah sure and there's a
lot of people that are talking about
this
republican convention in texas and their
platform and i just would like to say
first of all there are way more people
in texas like me sure than there are
republicans there are we're known as the
st the land of people who don't vote
okay
and this
platform was a gift from sweet baby
jesus i swear to god it really was i
mean for them to codify
how freaking nuts
they are
so how do you do you say do you say this
can you say this can used as fodder in
the midterm election is that kind of
what you're getting at there is is that
this is ammunition for the democratic
party is that what you're saying
ammunition this is a nuclear bomb
i mean there is no way to not vote
there's no way to not vote you just
cannot do it if you if we're gonna we're
gonna take each and every plank in that
republican party and we're gonna rip it
off and then we're gonna beat the hell
out of republicans with it is what we're
going to do especially the i've seen a
lot of people talking about uh and i
want to see my texas paul people in the
chat here i'm talking about oh we're
going to secede you know what that is
that's republican babies and i'm digging
my ball and going home
i mean texas isn't going anywhere
we
live off the federal government
you have no idea how much of texas
budget comes straight out of the federal
government we cannot live without these
bases we cannot live without the
largesse of the federal government
period and i tell you the executives of
all these major oil companies
it's a hundred degrees and dry outside i
guarantee you they are in their
compounds up in connecticut
living the
the fat life where it's nice and cool
they are not here in texas and they are
not going to let texas secede so
that's over with
um there is one other thing that i'd
like to bring up and i'd like to see my
texas paw people in the chat hashtag
this we are in the
um you know we do excellent coverage
here at mmn the midas touch
folks just work their asses off to make
sure that any subject that comes up we
have somebody on breaking news to handle
it
uh we're in the middle of the
million subscriber challenge i want to
see hashtag million subscriber challenge
everybody that is watching this
hit the subscribe button and you don't
just hit the subscribe button i mean
it's free all this coverage is free to
you
you know
they went out they bought their own feed
for you so that you know even if
somebody misses this you can come back
and catch it later
we need you to go to a brother or sister
or a friend or
wife or whatever and say hey subscribe
to go to youtube subscribe to midas
touch and let's get let's get that
subscriber count but up well over a
million
listen listen to texas paul he's he's
really helping us out today i appreciate
it paul can you can you stick around for
um maybe some middle hearing i i really
want some texas paul
attitude at the break if i can i i
really think the midas mighty in the
chat would would appreciate that i i
need i need a breakdown of that first
panel in the texas absolutely you know
you know i you know you know we are
some people have said somehow we're
we're related now i don't i don't
believe that's the truth
but um but
both good looking well i mean i mean we
are we are with some of the best looking
on the on the you know on the midas
media network that is that is a good
question
where is jordy's cookies today by the
way yeah i don't i don't see you've got
uh jordy's cookies there
i mean it i want to see in that chat i
am watching the chat right now i want to
see hashtag million subscriber challenge
millions everybody
friends and families let's get that
subscriber count up over a million we
picked up yesterday get this tony
just yesterday we picked up 8 000 new
subscribers
in one half a day
texas paul on the million subscriber
challenge thank you paul for joining us
um
stick around hopefully we can we can
bring you back i'm going to bring in
speaking of uh
midas i've got uh brett mizellis with me
here let's see if we can bring in one of
the uh midas touch brothers brett how
are you i'm doing great are you feeling
better i know yesterday you weren't uh
feeling so well i think i am i'm hopped
up on a lot of drugs but i'm feeling
yeah i am feeling uh much better today i
was uh i was unable to even do the midas
touch podcast yesterday and i missed
being able to speak with everybody and i
think it was the first podcast i
actually ever missed in my
time of doing midas touch so that's how
you know how sick i was but i am doing a
lot better right now and it's great to
be here and i think we're set up right
now for one of the most powerful january
6th hearings yet and it's so important
that everybody watch and it's so
important that everybody tell their
friends to watch
well i'll tell you here's here's a live
shot of the room um of the live feed
coming in from the cameras that texas
paul was talking about let me bring in
my my co-host gabe sanchez here um gabe
what do you make of some of the uh
guests here i know you probably have
some questions for brett about them as
well
yeah i uh i'm very interested i mean i
know that you know uh like michael cohen
said i don't think we're gonna get much
new out of uh out of brad but um
it would it will still be good to hear
those things out of his actual you know
mouth you know not despite the fact that
he may
around the fact or roundabout still vote
for trump in 2024 if he runs but it will
still be good to hear him kind of from
his from the horse's mouth give his own
account of what went down when he got
that phone call um as well as you know
hearing from the poll worker i think
that's going to be very very good to
hear from someone who is actually on the
ground floor
dealing with this and saying there was
no fraud i was just collecting ballots
and doing my job
um
but organizations like newsmax owen and
fox news continue to perpetuate this
this lie
that we were all cheating
so i think this will be very good to
hear from just not uh not leadership
people but actual people who are you
know common everyday people just like
ourselves so well
yeah go go ahead break because i was
yeah i was going to make the point that
everyday people it seems it seems uh to
me that it's significant that the
election worker is on the second panel
by themselves what do you think of that
i mean that seems significant is it well
i think you're talking about shay moss
and i think it's going to put a lot of
eyeballs on her testimony in particular
i mean you got to understand shay moss
was a jfk profile and courage award
winner along with rusty bowers by the
way who's the arizona election worker in
the first half of this tell everyone
what the jfk uh profile encourage is to
kind of explain that to him because i
think that's significant
yeah well you know it's awarding people
who step out and you know put their
lives on the line for our democracy
right and here we have two people on
this panel who did just that who defied
their own party and were the uh
as a result were the
target of vicious smears and vicious
threats i mean sheamus literally had to
change her appearance she had to go into
hiding because of racist taunts and
death threats that were because of
people like donald trump and rudy
giuliani they basically put a hit on
this woman because she decided to
actually say that the election was a
legitimate election so i think that will
also show donald trump's criminality and
rudy giuliani's criminality here and not
only were they trying to overturn the
results but like a mafia boss they were
trying to actually target and put hits
on the people who refused to go along
with their plot and the reason why i
think even though gabe you and michael
cohen even though you guys say like you
know what we all heard raffensberger we
all heard the tape like we all know it
you know the thing is like americans in
particular and and people in general
though have short attention spans and
people forget about these things and
they feel very distant and i think what
the january 6 committee has been able to
do so effectively is they've been able
to able to present things and package
them in new ways that makes them feel
current and makes them people feel the
urgency of the moment right now and i
think you're seeing that be reflected in
the polls i mean the fact that you got
an eight to ten point bump in people who
think that donald trump should be
criminally charged since the hearings
started show that the people who may not
have been paying attention are now
starting to pay attention and to tune in
so you cannot tell me that people don't
care about this or that people aren't
seeing what is going on and i think it's
important to constantly refresh people's
minds because the republican party
actually thrives on gaslighting as we
all know and the ability to gaslight
also happens because you're kind of
distant a little from actions that
happen like they could say oh there were
no empty shelves when donald trump was
president there was no it's like dude we
all remember that i couldn't even buy
toilet paper when donald trump was
president but they rely on this fact
that people forget oh gas was a dollar a
gallon in january 6. no it was not and
our country was under attack and we
literally couldn't even like go out to
the store so like like they thrive on
gas lighting so anytime you could
counter that gas lighting with facts and
with shoving those facts in people's
face in a new way i do think it is
incredibly important
let me let me bring in let me bring in
um a few other bros and david bender um
is joining us as well david welcome and
ben and jordy jordy's got his popcorn
ready there um
paul is mike working today is it is it
working let's see the moment of truth
that's already a win look i know i'm
gonna go against popular opinion here
that's been said on the panel we're
gonna hear some electrifying stuff the
j6 committee has been flawless in their
execution each each hearing man you hear
something new i'm pumped i'm excited i
got my popcorn ready this is this is
history right now jordy rant the jordan
rant dropped i just want to i just want
to clarify i'm not saying that what brad
is going to say is going to be uh is
like whatever i i agree i mean it takes
you seven times to hear someone's name
to remember what it is so it i i totally
agree with what you're saying in terms
of beating you know beating the horse
here and repeating again and again just
saying trump made this call he said
these things he what he did have intent
he knew it was illegal he continued to
do it with even though that everyone
told him it was illegal and he still
continues to this day even on truth
social to to continue to beat down this
idea that it was all rigged so i played
i played a clip earlier of him saying on
newsmax
complain complain complain and complain
for so ben what do you make of these
complaints and is is rusty bowers brad
rather burger sterling and this election
worker gonna bring some light to these
complaints quote unquote that everyone
does and it's not illegal i was just
operating my freedom of speech i think
he said yesterday on another trader news
network i believe somewhere so well tony
these weren't complaints these were
crimes right and these were crimes that
were
uh targeted at the country um that were
targeted at individuals to overthrow our
democracy you know jordy has this
popcorn out but i'm wearing my colin
kaepernick jersey to watch today's
january i see six hearings and the
reason i am is because you go back in
the trump presidency
with his plan to attack private citizens
and private individuals and to use the
power of our great country to attack
people for just taking their own
principled positions and we saw that
beginning in the beginning of the trump
administration with people like colin
kaepernick but then at the end of it
when the election didn't go his way he
would attack everyone these weren't
complaints i mean shane moss was someone
who was working at the state farm arena
doing her civic duty you know just to
basically count votes you know right
and to help with an election being a
volunteer too a volunteer and have no
doubt what donald trump was trying to do
with shane moss was to
threaten her life to encourage people to
kill her so that she would be afraid and
would say things that would be favorable
to him to save her life that's what he
was doing there and then you go through
the other people whether it's rusty
bowers the arizona speaker of the house
or brad rafensberger the republican
georgia secretary of state or the chief
operating officer gabe sterling these
were individuals who donald trump
targeted um
with crime sought to extort them
remember what he said to brad
rapisberger wasn't just find me the
votes
it was find me the votes or else right
i am going to do things with the power
of my us attorneys and you remember they
had that u.s attorney on uh from georgia
who would have been the individual who
trump was trying to pressure to
criminally prosecute brad raffensberger
for not finding him the votes so it
wasn't just find me the votes the
extortion was or else right you can hear
that from raffensberger we're going to
hear that from sterling we're going to
hear that from rusty bowers and all of
them are going to say that trump acted
with
criminal intent that's what's going to
come out of this that this was trump
people are saying oh today's the day of
arizona and today's georgia
i think today is the day where trump not
john eastman not ken
trump right splinter stage and how he
was directly involved in all of us and
if you remember ben they also had
drafted a letter at doj to actually
say that there was fraudulent activity
happening in the georgia elections they
had that drafted and never ended sending
it i don't believe but they were
plotting the coup in plain sight with
that draft letter that even goes beyond
the phone call to show you that trump
was using the full weight of the justice
system in order to commit his crimes and
i think you know when you look at all
the actions of trump here threatening
these election officials rudy giuliani
threatening these election officials
leading up to even the greitens ad that
we saw yesterday of him threatening
rhinos to hunt rhinos and kill rhinos
what you see and this is something that
you won't hear in the mainstream media
but i'm not afraid to say it here the
republican party has become a terrorist
party this is a fascist terrorist party
and i'm not afraid to say that and we
all need to be calling it out because
once you're making threats in order to
get your political way you have become a
terrorist in that case and the fact is
when merrick garland is looking at the
case before him as the january 6
committee is looking at the case before
him what we can't do is we can't allow
these terrorist threats to work that is
the worst thing we could do we cannot
take these threats and say you know what
we're not going to act on criminal
indictments because we're scared of the
reaction you know what we're not going
to go after x y and z because we're
scared of the repercussions no that's
actually all the reason why we do need
to act and why we do need to see
indictments and why we do need to expose
all of the people involved because that
is not the united states of america
david what do you make of these
witnesses and who do you expect to come
out as maybe the most important witness
of the day we've seen these different
panels and always seems that a piece of
testimony or one of the witnesses
emerges as quote unquote the most
important so what do you expect from
these banners
well first of all let me say that the
one thing that i do know for sure is
that brett will get a lot better if he
has some of jordy's cookies
[Laughter]
you know
i don't share it david i don't care that
we can solve right in front of us let's
deal with what we have and
work for that so once that's taken care
of let me tell you what i i think is
coming and something that breaks us
that's very important
this is each one of these puzzle pieces
the seven prongs that liz cheney's been
talking about right we have seven
hearings uh the two next week have not
been announced yet uh we should hear
today uh that it's a week from today but
it's not that it's not set yet
but
thursday is going to be just as brett
said it's going to be about that letter
that was at the department of justice
ready to go out
uh to continue the pressure on the
states each of these things complements
what has come before and sets up what is
coming after they are doing a series of
dominoes that they're pushing over liz
cheney being the through line she's our
she's our narrator she's if this were uh
our town she'd be the stage manager
and she's doing it brilliantly she's
telling us the story so your your
question was who today is gonna pop
well i think
obviously all of the witnesses
up until we see uh and you see rusty
bowers coming in followed by brad
rothensberger and his deputy uh
gabe sterling
uh all taking their places at the table
all the witnesses all those people are
republicans
every single witness before this
committee
through today has been a republican
a trump republican in large part
uh the only the first witness who we
don't know her uh sheamus we don't know
her affiliation she's been a long time
worker her mother came in as a volunteer
all of them have had death threats
i i do think that is going to be a story
the reason she's alone there this
afternoon is because people are going to
hear some things they're going to make
their
blood curdle they're going to think this
could have happened to me and my mother
uh and that's that's a very human face a
human story much the same way the
capitol police officer was on the first
day
uh people need to understand their
consequences when this man gabe sterling
said people are going to get
killed he said it in december
he was right
people did get killed
and uh people are now saying adam
kinsinger said yesterday when he
explained how he and his wife and his
five-month-old baby had been threatened
with execution
more people are going to get killed
and that's because donald trump
continues
to say these things
as recently as yesterday and will again
today so i think i watch for all of
these panelists are going to be
important for different reasons i think
there's some things film that we're
going to see that we haven't seen before
but i think sheamos is going to be
important in a very visceral and
personal way that anybody can identify
with could it happen to anyone not
everyone is secretary of state but
everyone
has a mother who
shouldn't have to go into hiding
uh with the support of the fbi and and
change their look and appearance so
that's what i think is going to happen
today but i'm i'm really
glad to see that what they're doing is
telling a story to the american people
and they're doing it carefully and
they're doing it well
well said
ben um do you think do you think um
we're gonna hear anything that we
haven't heard from rathesburger or
sterling um i know uh rusty bowers this
is one of the first times he'll actually
speak in public about this so i know
we'll probably hear some new stuff from
him and also moss the election worker
but we've we've heard the tape right
like
brad raptors burger
speaking to trump had it in his mind hey
i better record this this guy's a
criminal right like he had that in his
mind so
are we going to hear anything new from
them do you think
i think how they're going to tell it is
going to contextualize it in a different
way post january 6th you know i think we
heard the audio we heard gabe sterling
he gave those press conferences leading
up to jan 6. we really haven't heard
from them in a meaningful way post jan 6
to put this all in context and i think
that's what you're gonna hear
today and i think there's also
additional information post jan sixth as
well you know in terms of you know just
seeing how these frivolous appeals have
played out across the country how the
lawyers who have filed these frivolous
lawsuits have been disbarred you know
just how garbage uh these uh phony
accusations by trump and his cronies
were and what damage it's done within it
i also think you're going to have
raffensberger a little more hyped up now
that he knows that the people still
voted him back into office i think he's
got a little bit of a chip on his
shoulder now knowing that the people are
with that and not trump so you're going
to see a more forceful
reference burger as well that's an
excellent point that's an excellent
point well i was going to i was going to
ask brett and then jordy i'll give you
just two seconds because you got to have
at least two seconds
bret you're a storyteller and i think
that's one thing that this is going to
put together today is a story right i
mean that's what they're really trying
to do is put this story together in a
way that the american people like you
said before can can watch this and say
oh that is the order that is the story
because there's so much there's so much
there
well i
i think also let's think about all the
tapes that we haven't heard yet i'm very
curious to actually see if there'll be
other tapes and more stuff that the
public has not even seen or heard and
i'm excited to get that context and i
think we will have some of those for
lack of a better phrase holy [ __ ]
moments uh during these hearings today
and i look forward to that and i also
want to encourage everybody as the
hearings are about to begin make sure
that you are subscribed to the midas
touch youtube channel and send this
stream right now to your friends and
family go and text it email it put it on
your facebook tweet it out make sure
that everybody is watching because the
american public needs to see exactly
what happened and that happens because
of you so subscribe share this and make
this the most watched hearings yet i
think that is so important isn't there a
million challenge going on there's a one
million subscriber challenge jordan 1
million subscribers what do you think
about the millionaire i know you're i
just want to say that brett totally
stole my line i was going to close it
with hey please subscribe to the channel
please share the link so instead of
doing that i'm just going to say ben
called me out last stream he said he's
the best public speaker of the brothers
my camera my mic weren't working i'd say
i challenge ben any day any day big bro
any day any day well we we see the we
see the witnesses here um having a
little bit of fun i don't think this
this uh smiles and fun is gonna last
very long once the committee enters the
room here i disagree with you tony
they're ready to take this guy down oh
you think it's like i think
those smiles you see they're like let's
freaking go here
here comes the chairman uh david i'll
give you the last part here before we
start well i i i'll tell you that today
is we're going to see adam schiff yet
again adam schiff is the uh
interlocutor today he will be
largely
asking the questions in this first panel
for sure
and we know what adam schiff is capable
of doing former uh prosecutor himself
he is ready for this moment the
republicans will hate it but he will be
really really good at it well thank you
fellas for joining us i appreciate it um
we're gonna go to the hearing now as
chairman thompson will gavel the hearing
in and we will hear from the witnesses
and hopefully
we'll have the story laid before us
of what happened in georgia
let's go to the hearing
the select committee to investigate the
january 6th attack on the united states
capitol will be in order without
objection the chair is authorized to
declare the committee in recess at any
point
pursuant to house deposition authority
regulation 10 the chair announces the
committee's approval to release the
deposition material presented during
today's hearing
good afternoon
at our last hearing we told the story of
a scheme driven by donald trump
to pressure former vice president mike
pence to illegally overturn the election
results
we showed that
when the pressure campaign failed and
mike pence fulfilled his constitutional
obligation
donald trump turned a violent mob loose
on him
we showed that the mob came within
roughly 40 feet
of the vice president
today
we'll show that what happened to mike
pence wasn't an isolated part of donald
trump's scheme to overturn the election
in fact
pressuring public servants into
betraying their oath
was a fundamental part of the
playbook and a handful of election
officials in several key states stood
between donald trump and the upending of
american democracy
as we began today
it's important to remember when we count
the votes for president we count the
votes state by state
for the most part
the candidates who win a popular vote in
a state
wins all the state's electoral college
votes and whoever wins the majority of
the electoral college votes
wins the presidency
so when donald trump tried to overturn
the election results he focused on just
a few states
he wanted officials at the local and
state level to say the vote was tainted
by widespread
fraud and throughout the results
even though as we showed last week there
wasn't any voter fraud that could have
overturned the election results
and like mike pence
these public servants wouldn't go along
with donald trump's scheme
and when they wouldn't embrace the big
lie
and substitute the will of the voters
with donald trump's will to remain in
power
donald trump worked to ensure they face
the consequences
threats to people's livelihood and lives
threats of violence that donald trump
trump knew about and amplified
and in
our other hearings
we can't just look backward at what
happened in late 2020 and in the early
2021 because the danger hadn't gone away
our democracy endured a mighty test on
january 6th and in the days before
we say our institutions hell
but what does that really mean
democratic institutions aren't
abstractions or ideas
they are local officials who oversee
elections
secretaries of state
people in whom we placed our trust that
they'll carry out their duties
but what if they don't
two weeks ago
new mexico held its primary elections
one county commission refused to certify
the results
citing vague unsupported claims
with dominion voting machines
the court stepped in
saying new mexico law required the
commission to certify the results
two of the three members of the
commission finally relented
one still refused
saying his vote quote
isn't based on any evidence it's not
based on any facts it's only based on my
gut feeling
and my own intuition
and that's all i need
by the way
a few months ago
this county commissioner was found
guilty
of illegally entering the capitol
grounds on january 6th
this story reminds us of a few things
first
as we've shown in our previous hearings
claims that widespread voter fraud
tainted the 2020 presidential election
have always been alive
donald trump knew they were alive and he
kept amplifying them anyway
everything we described today the
relentless destructive pressure campaign
on state and local officials was all
based on a lie
donald trump knew it
he did it anyway
second the lie hasn't gone away
it's corrupting our democratic
institutions
people who believe that lie are now
seeking positions of public trust
and as seen in new mexico
their oath to be
to the people
they serve will take a back seat to
their commitment to the big lie
if that happens
who will make sure our institutions
don't break under the pressure
we won't have close calls
we'll have a catastrophe
my distinguished colleague from
california mr schiff will present much
of the select committee's finding on
this matter
first i'm pleased to recognize our vice
chair ms cena of wyoming for any opening
statement she cared to offer
thank you very much mr chairman
today we will begin examining president
trump's effort to overturn the election
by exerting pressure on state officials
and state legislatures
donald trump had a direct and personal
role in this effort as did rudy giuliani
as did john eastman
in other words the same people who were
attempting to pressure vice president
mike pence to reject electoral votes
illegally
were also simultaneously working to
reverse the outcome of the 2020 election
at the state level
each of these efforts to overturn the
election is independently serious
each deserves attention both by congress
and by our department of justice
but as the federal court has already
indicated these efforts were also part
of a broader plan
and all of this was done in preparation
for january 6th
i would note two points for particular
focus today
first
today you will hear about calls made by
president trump to officials of georgia
and other states
as you listen to these tapes
keep in mind what donald trump already
knew at the time he was making those
calls
he had been told over and over again
that his stolen election allegations
were nonsense
for example this is what former attorney
general bill barr said to president
trump about allegations in georgia
we
took a look hard look at this ourselves
and based on our
review of it including the interviews of
the key witnesses uh the fulton county
uh
allegations were no merit
the the ballots under the table
uh were legitimate
ballots they weren't in a suitcase they
had been pre-opened for eventually
feeding into the machine all the stuff
about the water leak and that there was
some subterfuge involved
we felt there was some confusion but but
there was no evidence of a subterfuge to
create an opportunity to feed things
into the count
and
so we didn't see any evidence of of
fraud in in the in the fulton county
episode
and acting deputy attorney general
richard donahue told donald trump this
and i said something to the effect of
sir we've done dozens of investigations
hundreds of interviews
the major allegations are not supported
by the evidence developed mr trump was
told by his own advisors that he had no
basis for his stolen election claims
yet he continued to pressure state
officials to change the election results
second you will hear about a number of
threats and efforts to pressure state
officials to reverse the election
outcome
one of our witnesses today gabriel
sterling explicitly warned president
trump about potential violence on
december 1st 2020 more than a month
before january 6th
you will see excerpts from that video
repeatedly today
it has all
gone
too
far
all of it
joe jennifer today asked for chris krebs
a patriot who ran sissa to be shot
a 20-something tech in gwinnett county
today has death threats and a noose put
out saying she hung for treason
because she was transferring a report on
batches from an ems to a county computer
so he could read it
it has to stop
mr president
you have not condemned these actions or
this language
senators you have not condemned this
language or these actions
this has to stop
we need you to step up and if you're
going to take a position of leadership
show some
my boss secretary raffensburg
his address is out there they have
people doing caravans from their house
they've had people come on to their
property
it has to stop
this elections this is the backbone of
democracy and all of you who have not
said a damn word are complicit in this
the point is this
donald trump did not care about the
threats of violence
he did not condemn them he made no
effort to stop them he went forward with
his fake allegations anyway
one more point
i would urge all of those watching today
to focus on the evidence the committee
will present
don't be distracted by politics this is
serious
we cannot let america become a nation of
conspiracy theories and thug violence
finally i want to thank our witnesses
today
for all of your service to our country
today all of america will hear about the
selfless actions of these men and women
who acted honorably to uphold the law
protect our freedom and preserve our
constitution
today mr chairman we will all see an
example of what truly makes america
great
thank you mr chairman i yield back
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentleman from california mr schiff
for an opening statement
thank you mr chairman and madam vice
chair
on november 3rd 2020 donald trump ran
for reelection to the office of the
presidency
and he lost
his opponent joe biden finished ahead in
the key battleground states of arizona
michigan wisconsin pennsylvania georgia
and elsewhere
nevertheless and for the first time in
history
the losing presidential candidate fought
to hold on to power
as we have seen in previous hearings
he did so through a variety of means
on election day he sought to stop the
counting of the vote knowing that the
millions of absentee ballots elections
officials would be counting on election
day
and thereafter would run strongly
against him and deliver a victory to joe
biden
next and when he could not stop the
counting
he tried to stop state legislatures and
governors from certifying the results of
the election
he went to court and filed dozens of
frivolous lawsuits making
unsubstantiated claims of fraud
when that too failed he mounted a
pressure campaign directed at individual
state legislators
to try to get them to go back into
session and either declare him the
winner
decertify joe biden as the winner
or send two slates of electors to
congress
one for biden
and one for him
and pressure vice president pence to
choose him
as the winner
but the state legislatures wouldn't go
along with this scheme
and neither would the vice president
none of the legislatures agreed to go
back into special session and declare
him
the winner
no legitimate state authority in the
states donald trump lost would agree to
appoint fake trump electors and send
them to congress
but this didn't stop the trump campaign
either
they assembled groups of individuals in
key battleground states and got them to
call themselves electors
created phony certificates associated
with these fake electors and then
transmitted these certificates to
washington and to the congress to be
counted during the joint session of
congress on january 6th
none of this worked
but according to federal district judge
david carter
former president trump and others likely
violated multiple federal laws
by engaging in this scheme
including conspiracy to defraud the
united states
you will hear evidence of the former
president and his top advisors direct
involvement in key elements of this plot
or what judge carter called a coup
in search of a legal theory
for as the judge explained
president trump's pressure campaign to
stop the electoral count did not end
with vice president pence
it targeted every tier of federal and
state elected officials
convincing state legislatures he said to
certify competing electors was essential
to stop the count and ensure president
trump's reelection
as we have seen in our prior hearings
running through this scheme was a big
lie that the election was plagued with
massive fraud and somehow stolen
you'll remember what pres the
president's own attorney general bill
barr said he told the president about
these claims of massive fraud affecting
the outcome of the election
and uh
i told him that the stuff that his
people were shuttling out to the public
were both was [ __ ] i mean that the
claims of fraud were [ __ ]
the president's lie was
and is a dangerous cancer on the body
politic
if you can convince americans that they
cannot trust their own elections
that any time they lose it is somehow
illegitimate
then what is left but violence to
determine who should govern
this brings us to the focus of today's
hearing
when state elections officials refused
to stop the count
donald trump and his campaign tried to
put pressure on them
when state executive officials refused
to certify him the winner of states he
lost
he applied more pressure when state
legislators refused to go back into
session and appoint trump electors he
amped up the pressure yet again
anyone who got in the way of donald
trump's continued hold on power after he
lost the election was the subject of a
dangerous and escalating campaign of
pressure
this pressure campaign brought angry
phone calls and texts armed protests
intimidation and all too often threats
of violence
and death
state legislators were singled out
so too were statewide elections
officials
even local elections workers
diligently doing their jobs were accused
of being criminals
and had their lives turned upside down
as we will show the president's
supporters heard the former president's
claims of fraud and the false
allegations he made against state and
local officials as a call to action
[Music]
election
[Music]
and then about 45 minutes later we
started to hear the noises outside my
home and that's my stomach sunk and i
thought it's me and they're and then
it's just we don't know
what's gonna i mean the uncertainty of
that was what
was the fear like are they coming with
friends are they gonna attack my house
i'm in here with my kid you know it's
i'm trying to put him to bed
and so it was um
that was the scariest moment just not
knowing what was gonna happen
this pressure campaign against state and
local officials spanned numerous
contested states
as you will see in this video produced
by the select committee
my name is josh roselmann i'm an
investigative counsel for the house
select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol beginning in late november 2020
the president and his lawyers started
appearing before state legislators
urging them to give their electoral
votes to trump even though he lost the
popular vote i represent
president trump along with jenna ellis
and
this is our fourth or fifth hearing
because
we won pennsylvania by a lot and we won
all of these swing states by a lot this
was a strategy with both practical and
legal elements the select committee has
obtained an email from just two days
after the election in which a trump
campaign lawyer named cleta mitchell
asked another trump lawyer john eastman
to write a memo justifying the idea
when do you remember
this coming up as an option in the
post-election period for the first time
right after the election it might have
been before the election eastman
prepared a memo attempting to justify
this strategy which was circulated to
the trump white house rudy giuliani's
legal team and state legislators around
the country and he appeared before the
georgia state legislature to advocate
for it publicly you could also do what
the florida legislature was prepared to
do which is to adopt a slate of electors
yourself
and when you add in the mix of the
significant statistical anomalies and
sworn evidence and video evidence of
outright election fraud i don't think
it's just your authority to do that but
quite frankly i think you have a duty to
do that to protect the
integrity of the election here in
georgia but republican officials in
several states released public
statements recognizing that president
trump's proposal was unlawful
for instance georgia governor brian kemp
called the proposal unconstitutional
while arizona house speaker rusty bowers
wrote that the idea would undermine the
rule of law
the pressure campaign to get state
legislators to go along with the scheme
intensified when president trump invited
delegations from michigan and
pennsylvania to the white house uh
either you or speaker chatfield did you
make the point to the president that you
were not going to do anything that
violated michigan law
i believe we do
uh whether or not it was those exact
words or not but we're i think that the
words that
i would have more likely used as we were
going to follow the law
nevertheless the pressure continued the
next day president trump tweeted quote
hopefully the courts and or legislatures
will have the courage to do what has to
be done to maintain the integrity of our
elections and the united states of
america itself the world is watching
he posted multiple messages on facebook
listing the contact information for
state officials and urging his
supporters to contact them to quote
demand a vote on decertification
in one of those posts president trump
disclosed mike shirkey's personal phone
number to his millions of followers
all i remember is
receiving
over
just shy of 4 000 text messages over a
short period of time
calling
to take action
it was a
loud noise loud consistent cadence so
you know
we heard that
that uh the uh trump
uh folks are calling and asking for
changes in the electors and you guys can
do this well you know they were
they were believing things that were
untrue
these efforts also involved targeted
outreach to state legislators
my name is angela mccallum i'm calling
trump campaign headquarters in
washington dc you do have the power to
reclaim your authority and send a
specified of electors that will support
president trump and vice president pence
from president trump's lawyers and from
trump himself
and i've become friendly with
legislators that i didn't know four
weeks ago
another legislator pennsylvania house
speaker brian cutler received daily
voicemails from trump's lawyers in the
last week of november
mr speaker this is rudy giuliani and
jenna ellis we're calling you together
because we'd like to discuss obviously
the election
hello mr speaker this is jenna ellis and
i'm here with mayor giuliani
hey brian it's rudy i really have
something important to call your
attention that i think really changes
things cutler felt that the outreach was
inappropriate and asked his lawyers to
tell rudy giuliani to stop calling but
giuliani continued to reach out
i understand that you don't want to talk
to me now
i just want to bring
some facts to your attention and talk to
you as a fellow republican
on december 30th trump allie steve
bannon announced a protest at cutler's
home we're getting on the road and we're
going down to cutler we're going to
start going to offices and if we have to
we're going to go to homes and we're
going to let them know what we think
about them there were multiple protests
i actually don't remember the exact
number there was at least three i think
outside either my district office or my
home um and you're correct my son my
then 15 year old son was home by himself
for the first one all of my personal
information was doxxed online
it was
my personal email my personal cell phone
my home phone number
in fact we had to disconnect our home
phone
for about three days because it would
ring all hours of the night and would
fill up with messages
brian cutler we are outside
clerks facing felony charges in michigan
poll watchers denied access these ads
were another element in the upper the
trump campaign spent millions of dollars
running ads online and on television
the evidence is overwhelming
call your governor and legislators
demand they inspect the machines and
hear the evidence public pressure on
state officials often grew dangerous in
the lead up to january 6th
[Applause]
what are we going to do
what can you and i do to escape
legislation besides killing although you
should not do that i'm not advising that
but i mean what else you need to do
right
the punishment for treason
is death
state pressure campaign and the danger
it posed to state officials and the
state capitals around the nation
was a dangerous precursor to the
violence we saw on january 6 at the u.s
capitol
today you will hear from rusty bowers
the republican speaker of the arizona
house of representatives
he will tell us about his conversations
with the president rudy giuliani and
john eastman
and what the president's team asked of
him and how his oath of office would not
permit it you will then hear from brad
raffensberger the republican secretary
of state of georgia who trump directed
to quote fined 11 780 votes
that did not exist
but just the exact number of votes
needed to overtake joe biden
you will also hear from gabriel sterling
the chief operating officer his chief
operating officer
about the spurious claims of fraud in
the elections in georgia
and who responding to a cascading set of
threats to his elections team
warned the president to stop
that someone was going to get killed
and you will hear from wandrea andrea
chamas
a former local elections worker in
fulton county georgia about how all the
lies about the election impacted the
lives
of real people who administer our
elections
and still do
you will hear what they experienced when
the most powerful man in the world the
president of the united states
sought to cling to power after being
voted out of office
by the american people
the system held
but barely
and the system held because people of
courage republicans and democrats
like the witnesses you will hear today
put their oath of to the country and
constitution
above any other consideration
they did their jobs as we must do ours
thank you mr chairman
and i yield back
i now welcome our first panel of
witnesses
we're joined today by a distinguished
legislator from arizona
rusty bowers who's a republican speaker
of the arizona house of representatives
mr bowell was first elected to the state
legislature in 1993 and has served as
speaker since 2019.
welcome speaker bowers
brad ratzensberger
is the 29th secretary of state of
georgia serving in this role since 2019
as an elected official and a republican
secretary ratzenberger
is responsible for supervising elections
in georgia and maintaining the state's
public records welcome mr secretary
gabriel sterling is the chief operating
officer in the georgia secretary of
state's office mr sterling was the
statewide voting system's implementation
manager for the 2020 election in georgia
responsible for leading the secretary of
state's response to the covet pandemic
and rolling out modernized voting
equipment
i will swear in our witnesses the
witnesses will please stand
and raise their right hand
do you swear are informed or formed on
the penalty of perjury that the
testimony you're about to give is the
truth whole truth and nothing but the
truth so help you god
thank you please be seated
that directly reflect that the witnesses
answered in the affirmative
speaker bowers thank you for being with
us today
you're the speaker of the arizona house
and a self-described conservative
republican
you campaigned for president trump and
with him during the 2020 election
is it fair to say that you wanted donald
trump to win a second term in office
please
yes sir thank you
and is it your understanding that
president biden was the winner of the
popular vote in arizona in 2020 yes sir
thank you pursuant to section 5c 8 of
house resolution 503
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
california mr schiff for questions
speaker bowers thank you for being with
us today um before
we begin with the questions that i have
prepared for you i wanted to ask you
about a statement
that former president trump issued
which i received just
prior to the hearing
have you had a chance to review that
statement
i my counsel called from arizona and
read it to me yes sir
in that statement i won't read it in its
entirety
former president trump
begins by calling you a rhino uh
republican name only
he then references a conversation
in november 2020
in which he claims that you told him
that the election was rigged and that he
had won arizona
to quote the former president during the
conversation
he told me the election was rigged and
that i won arizona unquote
did you have such a conversation with
the president i did have a conversation
with the president
um
that certainly isn't it
but there were parts of it that are true
but there are parts that are not sir
and the part that i read you uh is that
false
anywhere anyone anytime has said that i
said the election was rigged
that would not be true
and when uh the
former president in a statement today
claimed
that you told him that he won arizona is
that also false
that is also false
mr bowers i understand that after the
election
and i don't know whether this is the
conversation the former president is
referring to
but after the election you received a
phone call from president trump and rudy
giuliani in which they discussed the
result of the presidential election in
arizona
if you would tell us about that call
uh and whether the former president or
mr giuliani raised allegations of
election fraud
thank you
my wife and i had returned from uh
attending our church meetings it was on
a sunday
and we were still in the driveway and
i had received a call from a colleague
telling me that the white house was
trying to get in touch with her and i
and that she
said please if you get a call let's try
to
take this together
immediately i saw that the white house
on my bluetooth was calling
and i took the call and was asked by the
i would presume the
operator at the white house if i would
hold for the president which i did and
he mr giuliani came on first
and
nice at ease
then mr trump president trump then
president trump came on
and
we initiated a conversation
and during that conversation uh did
um
you will ask mr giuliani for proof of
these allegations of fraud that he was
making on multiple occasions yes and
when you asked him uh for evidence of
this frog what did he say
you said that they did have proof and i
asked him
do you have names
for example you have 200 000 illegal
immigrants some large number
of five or six thousand dead people
etc and i said do you have their names
yes
will you give them to me yes
the president interrupted and said give
the man what he needs rudy he said i i
will and that happened on at least two
occasions that interchange in the
conversation
so mr giuliani was claiming in the call
that there were hundreds of thousands of
undocumented people and thousands of
dead people who had uh purportedly voted
in the election yes
and you asked him for evidence of that i
did
and did he ever receive did you ever
receive from him that evidence either
during the call after the call or to
this day never
what was he ask during this call
he was making these allegations of fraud
but he had something or a couple things
that they wanted you to do what were
those
the ones i remember were first the
that we would hold
that i would
allow an official committee
at at the capitol so that they could
hear this evidence
and that we could take action thereafter
and i refused
i said
up to that time the the circus i called
it circus had been brewing
with
lots of demonstrations both at the
accounting center at the capitol and
other places
and i didn't want to have that in the
house
i i did not feel that the evidence
granted in its absence
merited
a hearing and i didn't want to be used
as a pawn
uh if there was some other
need that the
that the committee hearing would fulfill
um so that was the first ask that we
hold an official committee hearing
and what was his second ask
i i said to what end
to what end the hearing
he said well we have heard
by an official high up in the republican
legislature
that there is a legal theory or a legal
ability in arizona
that you can remove the
um
[Music]
the electors of president biden and
replace them
and we would we would like to have the
legitimate opportunity
through the committee to come to that
end and
and remove that and i said that's
that's something that's totally new to
me i've never heard of any such thing
and he pressed that point
and i said look
you are asking me to do something
that is counter to my oath
when i swore to the constitution to
uphold it
and i also swore
to the constitution and the laws of the
state of arizona
and this is totally foreign as an idea
or a theory to me
and i would never
do anything
of such magnitude without deep
consultation with qualified attorneys
and i said i've got some good attorneys
and i'm going to give you their names
but you're asking me to do something
against my oath and i will not break my
oath
and
i think that was up to that point
during the conversation
and you heard i think when we played
um a snippet of mr giuliani calling
other state legislators and saying that
he was calling us essentially a fellow
republican did he make a similar appeal
to you or bring up the fact that you
shared a
similar party whether it was in that
call or in a later meeting he did bring
that up more than once
and how would he bring that up he would
say aren't we all republicans here i i
would think we would get a better
reception i mean i would think you would
listen
a little more open to my suggestions
that we're all republicans
and this uh this evidence that you
asked him for that would justify this
extraordinary step
i think you said they never produced why
did you feel either in the absence of
that evidence
or with it what they were asking you to
do would violate your oath to the
constitution
first of all when the people in arizona
i believe is some 40-plus years earlier
the legislature had established the
manner of electing our officials or the
electors for the presidential
race
once it was given to the people
as in bush vigor illustrated by the
supreme court
it becomes a fundamental right of the
people
so as far as i was concerned for someone
to ask me
in the
i would call it a paucity there was no
no evidence being
presented of any
strength
evidence can be hearsay evidence it's
still evidence but it's still hearsay
but strong judicial quality evidence
anything
that would say to me
you have a doubt
deny your oath
i will not do that
and
on more than
on more than one occasion throughout all
this that has been brought up
and it is a tenet of my faith
that the constitution is
divinely inspired
of my most basic foundational beliefs
and so for me to do that because
somebody just asked me to
is foreign to my very being i i will not
do it
during that conversation speaker bowers
um
did you
ask him if what he was proposing had
ever been done before i did
and what did he say
he said well i'm not familiar with
arizona law or any of the laws but i
um
i don't i don't think so and that also
was brought up in other conversations
both with him and with
john eastman and others
speaker bowers i understand that a week
after that call mr giuliani appeared
with others associated with president
trump's effort to overturn
the result of the election at a
purported legislative hearing in a hotel
ballroom in phoenix
was this an official hearing of the
state legislature it was not and and why
was it not a
real or official hearing of the
legislation a legislator can hold a
group meeting you can call it a hearing
but when
they ask me to have an official hearing
we establish it by protocols
public notice
etc
it's typically held at the capitol but
doesn't need to be
we can authorize a hearing off
campus
and in this case i had been asked
on several occasions to allow a hearing
i denied it but said you're free to hold
a meeting any meeting you want to the
person who asked
and which he ultimately did
i think he was a little frustrated but
he ultimately did
this uh this
meeting was the same day i believe that
the governor of arizona doug ducey
certified biden
as the winner of the presidential
election in arizona
did you meet with mr giuliani and his
associates while they were in phoenix uh
sometime after that purported
legislative hearing at the hotel yes i
did sir
and at that meeting did mr giuliani
raise any specific allegations of
election fraud again
uh his
initial comments were again the litany
of groups of
illegal individuals or
people deceased etc
and he had brought that up and
i wasn't alone in that meeting there
were others and other members of the
senate
uh aggressively questioned him
and then i
proceeded to question him on the proof
that he was going to bring me et cetera
but he did bring those up yes and these
other legislatures legislators were also
republican members of the senate they
were yes sir
uh and did they also press him for proof
of these allegations
they pressed him
very strongly
two of them especially very strongly
uh and at some point uh did mr giuliani
ask one of the other attorneys
on his team to help him out with the
evidence he did he asked jenna ellis who
was sitting to his right
uh
one thing was that it was more to the
point
of was there sufficient
evidence or action
that we could
justify the recalling of the electors
but at that part of the conversation i
know he he referred to someone else but
he did ask do we have the proof to jenna
miss ellis
and she said yes and i said i want the
names do you have the names yes
do you have
how they voted
we have all the information i said can
you get to me
that information did you bring it with
you
she said no
both
mr giuliani asked her and i asked
generally if they'd brought it with them
she said no it's not with me but we can
get it to you
and i said then you didn't bring me the
evidence
which was repeated in different
iterations for some period of time
at some point did uh one of them uh make
a comment that uh
they didn't have evidence but they had a
lot of theories that was mr giuliani and
what exactly did he say and how that
come up my recollection he said
we've got lots of theories we just don't
have the evidence
and i don't know if that was a gaff or
maybe he didn't think through what he
said but both myself and others in my
group the three in my group and my my
counsel
both remembered that specifically and
afterwards we kind of laughed about it
and you know getting back to the asking
that phone call that preceded this
meeting
he wanted you to
[Music]
have the legislature dismiss the biden
electors and replace them with trump
electors on the basis of these theories
of fraud
he did not say it in those exact words
but he did say that he
that arizona law according to what he
understood that that would be allowed
and that we needed to come into session
to take care of that which initiated a
discussion about
again what i can legally and not legally
do and i can't go into session arizona
unilaterally or on my sole prerogative
in this meeting or at any other later
time did anyone provide you with
evidence of election fraud sufficient to
affect the outcome of the presidential
election in arizona
no one provided me ever such evidence
the subcommittee has uncovered evidence
in the course of our investigation that
it stopped the steel protests at state
capitals across the country
there were individuals with ties to the
groups of parties involved in the
january 6th attack on the u.s capitol
one of those incursions took place in
the arizona house of representatives
building as you can see in this footage
this is previously undisclosed video of
protesters illegally entering and
refusing to leave the building
one of the individuals prominently shown
in this video
is jacob chansley
perhaps better known as the q anon
shaman this rioter entered the capitol
on january 6th
was photographed leaving a threatening
note on the diocese in the u.s senate
chamber and was ultimately sentenced to
41 months in prison
after pleading guilty to obstruction of
an official proceeding
other protesters who occupied the
arizona house of representatives
building included included proud boys
while men armed with rifles stood just
outside the entrance
i understand these protesters were
calling for you by name speaker bowers
is that correct that is correct
speaker bowers did the president call
you again in late uh later in december
he did sir
did you tell the president in that
second call that you supported him that
you voted for him but that you were not
going to do anything illegal for him i
did sir
nevertheless his lawyer john eastman
called you some days later on june 4th
2000 2021
and he did have a very specific ask that
would have required you to do just what
you had already told the president you
wouldn't do
something that would violate your oath
is that correct that's correct it wasn't
just me i had my counsel and others on
the on the on the call
and what did uh dr eastman want you to
do um
that we would
in fact vote to take a vote to
overthrow
or i shouldn't say overthrow
that we would decertify the electors and
that that because we had plenary
authority to do so
and
he cited article two section one i think
it's clause two
and
uh said that in his opinion that gave us
the authority if there was
i don't recall him saying sufficient
evidence but there was some call or some
strong reason to do so that we or
justification to do so that we could do
that
and that he was asking that we he his
suggestion was that we would do it and i
said
uh again
i took an oath
for me to take that
to do what you do would would be counter
to my oath
i don't recall if it was in that
conversation
clearly that
we talked more about the oath but i said
what would you have me do
and he said
just do it and let the court sort it out
and i said you're asking me
to do something that's never been done
in history
the history of the united states
and i'm going to put my state through
that
without
sufficient
proof
and that's going to be good enough with
me
that i would i would put us through that
my state
that i swore to uphold both in
constitution and in law
no sir
he said well that's my suggestion would
be
just just do it and let the courts
figure it all out and i he didn't use
that exact phrase but
that was what he
his meaning was and i
declined and i believe that was close to
the end of our phone call
and again this took place after you had
recently spoken with president trump and
told him that you wouldn't do anything
illegal for him is that right it wasn't
days after
obviously it was days after but a few
days had gone by but you had told
president trump you would not do
anything illegal for him i did
both times
and you told dr eastman that you did not
believe there was legal support to
justify
what he was asking but he still wanted
you to do it and effectively
let the courts
work it out
i've been warned don't say things you
think maybe he said
but i do remember him saying that the
authority of the legislature was plenary
and that you can do it i said then you
should know that i can't even call the
legislature into session
without a two-thirds majority vote
we're only thirty plus one
i i there's no way that could happen
but in your view what he was asking you
to do would have violated your oath to
the constitution both the united states
constitution and the constitution of the
state of arizona yes sir
did you also receive a call from u.s
representative andy biggs of arizona
on the morning of january 6th i did
and what did mr biggs ask you to do
i believe that was the day that the
vote was occurring
to
each state to have certification
or to declare the certification of the
electors
and he asked if i would
sign on both to a letter that had been
sent from my state
and or that i would support
the decertification of the electors and
i said i would not
mr speaker on december 4th 2020 shortly
after your meeting with rudy giuliani
and other allies of president trump he
released a statement publicly addressing
quote calls for the legislature to
overturn the 2020
certified election results the statement
is very straightforward in explaining
the quote breathtaking request unquote
made by representatives of president
trump
quote that the arizona legislature
overturned the certified results of last
month's election and deliver the state's
electoral college votes
to president trump unquote
why did you believe as you wrote in this
statement that the rule of law forbid
you from doing what president trump and
his allies wanted you to
do um representative i'm sorry i should
be saying
mr chairman
of representative chef
the
um
there's two sides to the answer one is
what am i allowed to do
and what am i forbidden to do
we have no
legal
pathway
both in state law nor to my knowledge in
federal law for us to execute such a
request
and i am not allowed to walk or act
beyond my authority
if i'm not specifically authorized as a
legislator as a legislature
then i cannot act
to the point of calling us into session
some say that just a few legislators
have plenty of authority
and that
has come as part of all of this
discussion i'll call it
but so
to to not have authority and be
forbidden to act beyond my authority on
both counts i am not authorized to take
such action and that would deny my oath
in your statement you included excerpts
from president ronald reagan's inaugural
address in 1981.
the newly inaugurated president told the
country quote the orderly transfer of
authority is called for in the
constitution
routinely takes place as as as it has
for almost two centuries
and few of us stop to think how unique
we really are
in the eyes of many in the world this
every four-year ceremony we accept as
normal is nothing less than a miracle
tell us if you would mr speaker why did
you include president reagan's words in
your public statement
um
mr chairman representative schiff
because
i have a lot of admiration for ronald
reagan
i
had the opportunity of going through his
home with one other person and
walking through and
i
have a lot of admiration for him
when
he um pointed out which is i
i have lived in other country
for a period of time
and have visited a few countries and
during election times
the fact that we
allow an election support an election
and stand behind the election even in
the past when there have been serious
questions about the election
and then move
on without
disturbance
and with acceptance
that we choose
we choose
to follow the outcome of the will of the
people
that will
it means a lot to me and i know it meant
a lot to him and so i we included that
thank you speaker bowers
i now want to look even more deeply at
the fake electors scheme
every four years citizens from all over
the united states go to the polls to
elect their president
under our constitution when we cast our
votes for president we are actually
voting to send electors
pledged to our preferred candidate to
the electoral college
in december the electors in each state
meet cast their votes and send those
votes to washington
there is only one legitimate slate of
electors from each state
on the sixth day of january congress
meets in a joint session to count those
votes and the winner of the electoral
college vote becomes the president
in this next segment you'll hear how
president trump and his campaign were
directly involved in advancing and
coordinating
the plot to replace legitimate biden
electors with fake electors not chosen
by the voters
you'll hear how this campaign convinced
these fake electors to cast and submit
their votes through fake certificates
telling them that their votes would only
be used in the event that president
trump won his legal challenges
yet when the president lost those legal
challenges when courts rejected them as
frivolous and without merit
the fake elector scheme continued
at this point
president trump's own lawyers so-called
team normal
walked away rather than participate in
the plan and his own white house
counsel's office
said that the plan was not
legally sound
let's play the following video produced
by the select committee
my name is casey lucia i'm an
investigative counsel for the house
select committee to investigate the
january 6 attack on the united states
capitol on november 18th a lawyer
working with the trump campaign named
kenneth cheesebro wrote a memo arguing
that the trump campaign should organize
its own electors in the swing states
that president trump had lost
the select committee received testimony
that those close to president trump
began planning to organize fake electors
for trump in states that biden won in
the weeks after the election
who do you remember being involved in
those early discussions around the
thanksgiving time
regarding having alternate electors meet
mr giuliani
several mr giuliani's associates mr
meadows
um
members of congress although it's
difficult to distinguish
if the members i'm thinking of were
involved during thanksgiving or if
they're involved
as we progress through december
at the president's direct request the
rnc assisted the campaign in
coordinating this effort what did the
president say when he called you
essentially he turned the call over to
mr eastman who then
proceeded to
talk about the importance of the rnc
helping the campaign gather
these contingent electors in case any of
the legal challenges
um that were ongoing change the result
of
any of these
i think more just helping them reach out
and assemble them but the
my understanding is the campaign did
take the lead
and
we just were
helping them in that in that role as
president trump and his supporters
continued to lose lawsuits some campaign
lawyers became convinced that convening
electors in states that trump lost was
no longer appropriate
i just remember i either replied or
called somebody saying
unless we have litigation pending that's
like in these states like i don't think
this is appropriate or you know this
isn't the right thing to do
i don't remember how i phrased it but
um
i got into a little bit of a back and
forth and i think it was with ken
cheeseborough um
where i said all right you know
you just get after it like i i'm out
at that point
um i had
josh finley email mr chesbro
politely to say
this is your task
you are responsible for the electoral
college
issues moving forward and this was my
way of taking that responsibility to
zero
the committee learned the white house
counsel's office also felt the plan was
potentially illegal and so to be clear
did you hear the white house counsel's
office say that
um this plan to have alternate electors
meet and cast votes for donald trump in
states that he had lost was not legally
sound yes sir
and who was present for that meeting
that you remember
mr it was in our offices mr meadows mr
giuliani and a few of giuliani's
associates the select committee
interviewed several of the individual
fake electors as well as trump campaign
staff who helped organize the effort we
were just you know kind of
kind of useful idiots or rubes at that
point you know a strong part of me
really feels that it's just kind of as
the road continued and as that was fail
your failure failure that that that got
formulated is what do we have on the
table
um let's just do it
and and now after what we've told you
today about the select committee's
investigation about the conclusion of
the professional lawyers on the campaign
staff justin clark matt morgan and josh
finley about their um unwillingness to
participate in the
convening of these electors
how does that contribute to your
understanding of these issues
i'm i'm
angry
i'm angry um
because i think
i think in a sense you know
no one really
cared uh if
if
people were potentially putting
themselves in jeopardy would you have
not wanted to participate in this any
further as well i absolutely would not
have
had i know that the three main lawyers
for the campaign
um that i've spoken to in the past and
were leading up
were were not on board
um
yeah
i was told that
these would only count if a court ruled
in our favor
so that would have been
um using our electors
um
well it would have been using our
electors
in ways that we weren't told about
um and we wouldn't have supported
documents obtained by the select
committee indicate that instructions
were given to the electors in several
states that they needed to cast their
ballots in complete secrecy
because this scheme involved fake
electors those participating in certain
states had no way to comply with state
election laws like where the electors
were supposed to meet one group of fake
electors even considered hiding
overnight to ensure that they could
access the state capitol as required in
michigan
did mr norton say who he was working
with at all on this effort to have
electors meet
he said he was working with the
president's campaign
he told me
that
the michigan republican electors were
planning to meet in the capitol
and hide overnight so that they could
fulfill the
role of casting their vote in per law in
the
michigan
chambers
and
i told him in knowing certain terms that
that was insane and inappropriate
in one state the fake electors even
asked for a promise that the campaign
would pay their legal fees if they got
sued or charged with a crime ultimately
fake electors did meet on december 14
2020 in arizona georgia michigan
pennsylvania new mexico nevada and
wisconsin at the request of the trump
campaign the electors from these
battleground states signed documents
falsely asserting that they were the
quote duly elected electors from their
state and submitted them to the national
archives and the vice president pence in
his capacity as president of the senate
here is what some of the fake elector
certificates look like as compared to
the real ones but these ballots had no
legal effect
in an email produced to the select
committee dr eastman told a trump
campaign representative that it did not
matter that the electors had not been
approved by a state authority quote the
fact that we have multiple slates of
electors demonstrates the uncertainty of
either that should be enough
he urged that pence act boldly and be
challenged
documents produced to the select
committee show that the trump campaign
took steps to ensure that the physical
copies of the fake elector's electoral
votes from two states were delivered to
washington for january 6.
text messages exchanged between
republican party officials in wisconsin
show that on january 4th the trump
campaign asked for someone to fly their
fake electors documents to washington
a staffer for wisconsin senator ron
johnson texted a staffer for vice
president pence just minutes before the
beginning of the joint session
this staffer stated that senator johnson
wished to hand deliver to the vice
president the fake elector's votes from
michigan and wisconsin
the vice president's aide unambiguously
instructed them not to deliver the fake
votes to the vice president even though
the fake elector slates were transmitted
to congress and the executive branch the
vice president held firm in his position
that his role was to count lawfully
submitted electoral votes joseph r biden
jr
of the state of delaware has received
306 votes
donald j trump of the state of florida
has received 232 votes
which is what he did when the joint
session resumed on january 6 after the
attack on the capitol
well we just heard in that video was an
aide to the white house chief of staff
telling this committee that the white
house counsel's office felt that this
fake elector's plan was not legally
sound
nevertheless the trump campaign went
forward with the scheme
anyway
speaker bowers were you aware that fake
electors had met in phoenix on december
14th and purported to cast electoral
votes for president trump i was not
when you learned that these electors had
met and sent their electoral votes to
washington what did you think
well
i thought of the book the gang that
couldn't shoot straight
and
i just
thought this is a
this is a tragic parody
mr bowers i understand that as you flew
from phoenix to washington yesterday
you reflected upon some passages from a
personal journal that you were keeping
in december 2020 while all this was
taking place
with your permission i'm wondering if
you would be willing to share one
passage in particular with us
thank you very much
it is painful to have friends
who have been such a help to me
turn on me with such rancor
i may in the eyes of men
not hold correct opinions or act
according to their vision or convictions
but i do not take this current situation
in a light manner
a fearful manner
or a vengeful manner
i do not want to be a winner by cheating
i will not play with laws i swore
allegiance to
with any contrived desire towards
deflection
of my deep foundational desire
to follow god's will
as i believe
he led my conscience to embrace
how else
will i ever approach him
in the wilderness of life
knowing that i ask this guidance only to
show myself a coward
in defending the course he let me take
he led me to take
thank you mr speaker those are powerful
words
i understand that taking the courageous
positions that you did
following the 2020 election
in defense of the rule law and
protecting the voters of arizona
resulted in you and your family being
subjected to protests and terrible
threats
can you tell us how this impacted you
and your family
well
as others in the videos have mentioned
we
received my secretaries would say
in excess of 20 000 emails and
tens of thousands of voicemails and
texts
which
saturated our offices and we were unable
to work
at least communicate
but at home
um
[Music]
up till even recently
it is the new
pattern or a pattern in our lives to
worry what will happen on saturdays
because we have
various groups come by
and
they have had
video panel trucks with videos of me
proclaiming me to be a pedophile and a
pervert and a corrupt and
politician
and
blaring
loudspeakers in my
neighborhood and
leaving literature both on my
property but
arguing and threatening with neighbors
and with myself
and i don't know if i should name groups
but there was a one gentleman that had
the three bars on his chest
and he had a pistol
and was threatening my neighbor not with
the pistol but just vocally
when i saw the gun i knew i had to get
close
and
at the same time
on some of these
we had
a daughter who was gravely ill
who was upset
by
what was happening outside
and my wife that
is a valiant person very
very strong
quiet
very strong woman
so it was disturbing
it was disturbing
mr speaker i want to thank you
for your service to the state of arizona
and to the country
mr chairman at this point i think it'd
be appropriate to take a short recess
accordingly i reserve the balance of my
time
the chair requests that those
in the hearing room remain seated until
the capitol police have escorted members
and witnesses from the room
we'll have
five minutes
five minute recess
okay so we're going to go to a recess
here i want to bring in karen agnipolo
to see what her thoughts are
of the hearing so far and some of the
testimony that we have heard
from the arizona house speaker
rusty bowers uh karen
uh how are you
i'm good i'm good trying to multitask
today yeah sure and do a few things um
wow was that powerful
i mean
that was palpably powerful right to talk
about what that meant to him
and
you know here here's a man who clearly
takes
his job very seriously
uh takes his oath very seriously
felt he was being asked to do something
that was not only
he was not permitted to do
but that he also
was morally obligated to
uphold his values his beliefs the
constitution
and
and he really
[Music]
withstood a lot of
attacks you know
and threats and his family was going
through a hard time and you could feel
that you could feel
you know and that and that's what that's
what prosecutors look for
when they're thinking about witnesses is
are they credible
and
credibility is something that you feel
that you can tell you know it's
something that that people can just tell
if something is authentic or not and
i think that was pretty powerful
and i think that's it just shows
you know the campaign of pressure that
was being put on states all around the
us i mean you know it's fascinating to
me the fact that that we in our
vocabulary that we're talking about fake
electors right i mean we're talking
about it as if this is somehow
you know normal
this is so not normal you know that that
we're talking about that the president
of the united states lost an election
and then asked i think i counted eight
states you know where where they were
coming up with fake electors right just
to try
to vote to do two things i think it was
to see if they can
make it so that he wins or
to at least have a question
to make it go to court and you know and
and somehow
figure out how to throw the election in
his favor i don't i don't quite
yeah so it's just the i i just can't
believe
you know i don't know are we are we have
we become sort of numb to all of this
that
that um
that you know i i don't know why i'm so
shocked you know well you know
that's good jessica denson uh let me
bring her in she spoke about uh faith
and um rusty bowers really struggled
with his faith it seemed like jessica
when he was talking about those things
um what did you make of some of the
struggle that he had not just with his
oath because he did mention that oath
several times but it was almost like
this
his faith was being was being pressured
um
you know as a christian
yeah it was extremely poignant and as i
understand rusty bowers is a mormon i'm
not a mormon we won't go down that
rabbit hole but i just i think this
really points out um the role that faith
plays if if you are exercising it it
really was his moral backstop it was
what was giving him the moral courage to
take the stand that he did
and
listen to him
talk about how he
his people were outside of his home with
guns listen to robert sinners talking
about he is the one who proposed a fake
elector's scheme and told the fake
electors to maintain absolute secrecy
even he
was angry at being used as a useful
idiot as a pawn for trump and and said
after he found out that the scheme was
illegal how angry he was
just step back and look at these people
who are being victimized these are
people on trump's team people who voted
for donald trump
we all they want us to frame this in a
political lens they want to say this is
democrats after trump democrats for
retribution
donald trump was after his own people
when they crossed him his own supporters
were killed on january 6th
restitution is restitution for the whole
country for his supporters for everybody
that's been duped and terrorized by his
lies and his
and even
justice for donald trump a
gift of truth that this man has never
been given so um
yeah i mean extremely poignant testimony
extremely moving and um please more of
this moral character from uh from
americans who have taken that that
sacred oath
well let me let me bring in a few more
americans here let me go to uh texas
paul and david bender um if they're
ready here uh texas paul what did you
make of the hearing there um with some
of the witness testimony from rusty
bowers talking about the pressure
campaign against him
not just from the trump allies but trump
himself
i tell you what my blood is just just
boiling listening to that i just it just
makes me want to just jump in my truck
and head over there and catch one of
these sons of [ __ ] driving that you
know one of those you've seen those
video panel trucks they they drive
around in every city in
in the country to advertise stuff but
blaring calling him a pedophile and when
he talked about his daughter being ill
and upset by this
i just
you know i just
i don't even have the words for tony i
just
i want to just smash these people's
heads into the pavement i just i just
i'm
i cannot handle this anymore this is
just not acceptable it's not acceptable
we cannot what we allow
is what we get and this just cannot be
allowed anymore this cannot be allowed
anymore you know it was melania i think
that said that that uh trump kept a copy
of mind confident in in his nightstand
he
this man believes he is hitler he
believes the proud boys it struck me
that you know the proud boys showed up
to and they were yelling
bowers name
you know just like just like they did in
the capital capital these are his brown
shirts he really has this freaking
delusion that he's hitler and that he's
going to be able to do this because if
you look at what he's doing
it it's it's verbatim what happened in
1930s germany
and
i just i
screw these people i mean i am really
paul you seem a little a little pissed
i'm just listening to him talk and
watching him
choke up talking about his daughter it
definitely it definitely is infuriating
that uh not just the trump allies but
trump himself was not just pressuring
his team but they were calling this the
speaker
of the house in arizona forcing him to
do something that he did not have the
legal authority to do even in just
having a hearing he can say he said you
can have all the meetings you want so
david what did you make of some of that
testimony because i thought that was
some of the the most pressure they put
on him was they were trying to get him
just to say
just to say
it's trump's election trump won and and
and i felt like that if they just
pressured him here and pressured him
there and they could get him to do these
little things then they could get him to
do the big thing that they really wanted
was to call the election and make it
trump's election and not the actual
truth which was that biden won arizona
we remember the line tony
just
uh
cast enough doubt on this this we're
gonna hear this on thursday with the
justice department just create enough
question about who won and let the
republican congressman do the rest i'll
take care of it from there
it it you don't have to prove anything
and we saw rudy giuliani turn to
jenella's and say did you bring it with
you do you do you have the evidence is
it here uh and and no no i left it at
home uh the dog ate it right um you know
i i it was deeply moving it is deeply
moving to see a person of conscience uh
speak to uh how and reading from his own
journal on the flight
here to
to washington from arizona this is all
real time
uh
real time donald trump attacking him
today
adamship reading under the record an
attack that happened
within the last two hours
so anyone who thinks this was over on
january 6th
uh may finally be able to see that it it
isn't it's ongoing and i i there's one
thing i want to say and and i was struck
by something that jessica said
any number of times before the broadcast
if you weren't listening you should
subscribe and get to a million here on
on this uh on this stream but jessica
you you made mention of your faith
and of the power of
of being
consistent with your faith
and what we saw with the witnesses
uh in the last hearing what we saw uh
judge ludig
talking about having prayed that morning
before he testified
what we saw from uh
the other witnesses who had talked about
the great jacob talking about prayer
citing bible verses
this is very much a moment where faith
has informed people to do
their moral duty even more than their
legal duty
and you heard that from the speaker just
now
he talked about his duty to an oath that
he took to a constitution that was
divinely inspired
and i think if we're paying attention
we're hearing something that should be
speaking directly to trump's base
evangelicals who have somehow
not
noticed
that
the book that trump has by his bedside
is actually not mine comp but the
speeches have made off hitler it's not
the bible
that's that's what i think these
hearings writ large are going to finally
show and when we start to move to peel
off some people
uh in their vision of trump as a great
man of god
they'll see that he is he is a false
prophet
that's that's my takeaway from today and
from the previous hearing and i think
we're gonna see more of it
i think we'll i think we'll hear a lot
here as the witnesses you see the
witnesses they're taking their place
back at the table um looks like rusty
bowers is
really
going at the water bottle i'm sure he's
um
with this the amount that he spoke and
the things that he said with the
conviction that he said um
tony
saw dave sterling's uh
statements which we're going to see
again and again i'll see him say it now
today but what he said in real time
people are going to get killed and how
emotional he was
i think we'll see that emotion again
today i think also keep in mind
and also keep in mind
there's a theme here they told rusty
bowers just do it and let the court sort
it out yep you watch that's going to be
a recurring theme through this entire
situation they think that they had the
courts fixed they think that they they
could delay this out until trump could
stay in office you watch maybe maybe the
name jeannie thomas uh will work its way
into that narrative eventually who knows
we'll see
and paul when we come back from this
afterwards let's talk about what could
happen when the court finally gets a
chance to rule on this which is where
they're headed
i think we're going to be going back to
the hearing soon thank you to the panel
for joining us through the break i
really do appreciate it um if you guys
stick around we'll try to bring you in
uh to the coverage in the panel after
the hearing
i'm i'm guessing we'll have the
remainder of panna one and panel two
um before the hearing ends
we may get another break but if we do i
i would guess another break tony okay
before they go to uh i i would say that
we might have a break before panel two
so uh stick around if you can uh panel
we'll we'll try to bring in if we get
another break thank you very much for
joining us i'm going to go back to the
hearing here i don't want to miss them
gaveling in from the break
again we see the witnesses here
arizona house speaker rusty bowers brad
rathersberger the georgia secretary of
state
and gabriel sterling the secretary of
state chief operating officer on panel
one
they will be continuing
the testimony here as soon as the
committee and here we see the committee
entering into the
the hearing room as benny thompson
leads them
to gavel back in from the break
i was wondering to myself as we were
going to a break when adam schiff kind
of
leaned over to benny thompson i don't
know if there was something that maybe
these the speaker of the house had said
arizona house speaker had said
rusty bowers
um that made them maybe want to
talk in private or maybe they just
needed a break
but it's worth a wonder there
let's listen in as
chairman thompson
will gavel back in the hearing
the committee will be in order
president trump's pressure campaign
against state officials
existed in all the key battleground
states that he lost
but the former president had a
particular obsession with georgia
here is the president on the afternoon
of january 6th
after his own attorney general
warned him that the claims you are about
to hear are patently false
you should find those votes
they should absolutely find that
just over 11 000 votes that's all we
need
they defrauded us out of a win in
georgia and we're not going to forget it
so the state of georgia is where we will
turn our attention to next
i want to emphasize that our
investigation into these issues
is still ongoing
as i stated in our last hearing
if you have relevant information or
documentary evidence to share with the
select committee we welcome your
cooperation
but we will share some of our findings
with you today
secretary rassenberger
thank you for being here today
you've been a public servant in georgia
since 2015
serving first as a member of the georgia
house of representatives and then since
january 2019
as georgia's secretary of state
as a self-described conservative
republican it is is it fair to say that
you wanted president trump to win the
2020 election
yes it is
mr secretary many witnesses have told
the select committee that election day
november 3rd 2020 was a largely
uneventful date in their own states
in spite of the challenges of conducting
an election doing a pandemic
you wrote in the washington post that
the election was quote successful
tell us
what was your impression of how election
day had proceeded in georgia
on election day in november
our election went remarkably smooth
in fact we meet at the gma headquarters
that's the georgia energy
emergency management association
meeting
location but we are following wait times
in line in the afternoon our average
wait time was three minutes statewide
that we were reporting for various
precincts and it actually got down to
two minutes
and at the end of the day we felt that
we had a successful election from the
standpoint of the administration and the
operation of the election
thank you let's see i recognize the
gentleman from california mr ship
thank you mr chairman
secretary robertsberger did joe biden
win the 2020 presidential election in
georgia and by what margin
uh
president biden carried the state of
georgia by approximately 12 000 votes
and mr secretary as i understand it your
office took several steps to ensure the
accuracy of the vote count in georgia
reviewing the vote count in at least
three different ways
these steps included a machine recount a
forensic audit and a full hand recount
of every one of the five million ballots
cast
did these efforts including a recount of
literally every ballot cast in the state
of georgia confirmed the result
yes they did we counted the abouts where
the first tabulation would be scanned
then when we did our 100
hand audit of the entire all five
million ballots in the state of georgia
all cast in place all absentee ballots
they were all hand recounted and they
came remarkably close to the first count
and then upon the election being
certified president trump because he was
in within half percent
excuse me could ask for every account
and then we recounted him again through
the scanners and we got remarkably the
same count three counts all remarkably
close which showed that president trump
did come up short
nevertheless as you will see the
president and his allies began in making
began making numerous false allegations
of voter fraud
false allegations that you and mr
sterling among others had to address
mr sterling thank you also for being
here today
following the 2020 election in addition
to your normal duties i understand that
you became a spokesperson to try to
combat disinformation about the election
and the danger it was creating for
elections officials among others
in a december 1 press conference you
addressed some of your remarks directly
to president trump
let's take a look at what you said that
day
mr president
it looks like you likely lost the state
of georgia
we're investigating there's always a
possibility i get in you have the rights
to go through the course what you don't
have the ability to do and you need to
step up and say this is stop inspiring
people to commit potentialize to
violence someone's going to get hurt
someone's going to get shot someone's
going to get killed
and it's not right
i i
that's not
right mr silly what prompted you to make
these remarks
mr schiff we had had a previously
scheduled press conference that day as
we were in the habit of doing trying to
be as transparent as we could about the
election and the counts going on
um a little after lunch that day
lunchtime i received a call from the
project manager from dominion voting
systems
who
was oddly audibly shaken she's not the
kind of person i would assume would be
that way she has a master's in mit a
graduate of naval academy and was very
much on the ball and pretty unpleasable
and she informed me about a young
contractor they had who had been
receiving threats
um from a video been posted by some q
anon supporters
and at that point we had been sort of
been steeping in this kind of stuff so
we were it was around us all the time so
i didn't take note of it
more than adding to the pile of other
stuff we were having to deal with
and i did pull up twitter and i scrolled
through it and i saw the young man's
name there was a particular tweet that
for lack of a better word was a straw
that broke the camel's back
um
had a young man's name
it's a very unique name i believe is a
first generation american
and as it had his name
you committed treason
may god have mercy on your soul with a
slowly twisting
gif of a noose
and for lack of a better word i lost it
i just got irate um
my boss was with me at the time the
deputy secretary jordan fusch and she
could tell that i was angry i'm turning
i tend to turn red from here up when
that happens and that happened at that
time
and she called secretary raffesburger to
say we're seeing these kind of threats
and
gabe thinks we need to say something
about it and secretary said yes and
that's what prompted me to do what
i did i lost my temper
but it seemed necessary at the time
because it was just getting worse and i
don't i could not tell you why that
particular one was the one that put me
over the edge but it did
after you made this plea to the
president did donald trump urge his
supporters to avoid the use of violence
not to my knowledge
now as we know the president was aware
of your speech because he tweeted about
it later that day
let's take a look at what the president
said
in the tweet
donald trump claims that there was quote
massive voter fraud in georgia
mr sterling that was just plain false
wasn't it
yes sir
nevertheless the very next day on
december 2nd president trump released a
lengthy video again making false claims
of election fraud in georgia
let's take a look at what he said this
time
they found thousands and thousands of
votes
that were out of whack all against me
in fact the day after donald trump
released that video so now we're talking
just two days after the emotional
warning
that you gave that someone's going to
get killed
of president trump appeared in georgia
including rudy giuliani
and launched a new conspiracy theory
that would take on a life of its own and
threatened the lives of several innocent
election workers
this story falsely alleges that sometime
during election night
election workers at the state farm arena
in atlanta georgia
kicked out poll observers
after the observers left the story goes
these workers pulled so-called suitcases
of ballots from under a table and ran
those ballots through counting machines
multiple times
completely without evidence president
trump and his allies claimed that these
suitcases
contained as many as eighteen thousand
ballots all for joe biden
none of this was true
but rudy giuliani appeared before the
georgia state senate and played a
surveillance video from state farm arena
falsely claiming that it showed this
conspiracy taking place
here's a sample of what mr giuliani had
to say during that hearing
and when you look at what you saw on the
video which to me was a smoking gun
powerful smoking gun
well i don't
don't have to be a genius to figure out
what happened
i don't have to be a genius to figure
out that those votes are not legitimate
votes
you don't put legitimate votes under a
table no
wait until you throw the opposition out
and in the middle of the night count
them
we would have to be fools to think that
president trump's campaign amplified
giuliani's false testimony in a tweet
pushing out the video footage
giuliani likewise pushed out his
testimony on social media
as you can see in this tweet mr giuliani
wrote that it was quote now beyond doubt
unquote that fulton county democrats had
stolen the election
later in this hearing we'll hear
directly from one of the election
workers in this video
about the effect these lies had on her
and on her family
mr sterling did the investigators in
your office review the entire
surveillance tape from the state farm
arena on election night uh they actually
reviewed approximately 48 hours going
over the time period where action was
taking place at the um accounting center
at state farm arena and what did the
tape actually show
depending on which time you want to
start because as was mentioned this
conspiracy theory took on a life of its
own
where they conflated a water main break
that wasn't a water main break and
throwing observers out and a series of
other things what it actually showed was
fulton county election workers engaging
in normal ballot processing
one of the specific things
one of the things was very frustrating
was the so-called suitcases of ballots
from under the table
if you watch the entirety of the video
you saw that these were election workers
who were under the impression they were
going to get to go home around 10 10 30.
people are putting on their coats
they're putting
ballots that are prepared to be scanned
into ballot carriers that are then
sealed with tamper-proof steel so that
you they can you know they're not messed
with
um
and the
it's an interesting thing because you
watch all there's four screens of the
video and as you're watching it you can
see the election monitors in the corner
with the press as they're taking these
ballot carriers and putting them under
the under the table you see it there
one of the other hidden ones if you
looked at the actual tape was on the
outside of the table just from the
camera angle you couldn't see it
originally
and this goes under the no good deed
goes unpunished we were told that we
were at jima as the secretary pointed
out and we were under that we were told
that it looked like they were shutting
down with fulton county accounting
the secretary expressed some displeasure
at that because we wanted to everybody
keep counting so we can get to the
results and know what was happening
so our elections director called their
elections director who was at another
location because this was election day
there was two different places where
ballot things were being done by the
fulton county office
um so he called the election secretary
fulton then called ralph jones who was
at the state farm arena and said
what the heck are you doing go ahead and
stay
as you watch the video itself you see
him take the phone call as people are
putting things away and getting ready to
leave
you can tell for about 15-20 seconds he
does not want to tell these people they
have to stay he walks over he thinks
about it for a second you see him come
back to the corner of the desk and kind
of slumps his shoulder says okay y'all
we got to keep on counting and then you
see him take their coats off get the
ballots out and then a secondary thing
that you'll see on there is you'll have
people who are counting ballots
who a batch will go through
they will take them off and run that
through again what happens there is a
standard operating procedure if there is
a miss scan if there's a misalignment if
it doesn't read right these are
high-speed high-capacity scanners so
three or four will go through after a
miss scan you have to delete that batch
and put it back through again
and by going through the hand tally as
the secretary pointed out
we showed that if had there been
multiple ballots scanned without a
corresponding physical ballot your
accounts would have been a lot higher
than the ballots themselves and by doing
the hand tally
we saw two specific numbers that were
met the hand tally got us to a point one
zero five three percent off of the total
votes cast and point zero zero nine nine
percent on the margin which is
essentially dead on accurate um most
academic studies say on a hand towel
you'll have between one and two percent
but because we use ballot marking
devices where it's very clear what the
voter intended made it a lot easier for
us to conduct that hand count and show
that none of that was true
now i understand that
when you reviewed these tapes and did
the analysis it disproved this
conspiracy theory
um but you still had to take a lot of
steps to try to make sure the public
knew the truth about these allegations
and you did frequent briefings for the
press
let's take a look at one of those press
briefings mr sterling that you held on
december 7th
to make the point that you just did
today
move on to what i'm going to call
disinformation monday
out of the gate
many of you all saw the video take from
state farm arena i spent hours with our
post-certified investigators uh justin
gray from wsb spent hours with us going
over this video to explain to people
that what you saw the secret suitcases
with magic ballots were actually ballots
that had been patched into those uh
absentee ballot carriers
by the wars in plain view of the
monitors and the
press and what's really frustrating is
the president's attorneys had this same
videotape
they saw the exact same things the rest
of us could see and they chose to
mislead state senators and the public
about what was on that video
i'm quite sure that they will not
characterize the video if they try to
enter into evidence because that gives
us the kind of thing that could lead to
sanctions
because it's obviously untrue they knew
it was untrue and they continue to do
things like this
mr sterling despite the efforts by your
office to combat this misinformation
misinformation by speaking out publicly
and through local media
you are unable to match the reach of
president trump's platform and social
media megaphone spreading these false
conspiracy theories
what was it like to compete with a
president who had the biggest bully
pulpit in the world to push out these
false claims
for lack of a better word it was
frustrating
but oftentimes i felt
our information was getting out but that
there was a
reticence
of people who needed to believe it to
believe it because
the president united states whom many
looked up to and respected was telling
them it wasn't true
despite the facts
and
i have characterized at one point it was
kind of like a shovel trying to empty
the ocean
and yes it was frustrating i even have
you know family members
who i had to argue with about some of
these things and i would show them
things and
the problem you have is you're getting
to people's hearts
i remember there's one specific an
attorney that we know that we showed and
walking through this wasn't true okay i
get that this wasn't true okay i get
that this wasn't five or six things but
at the end he goes i just know in my
heart they cheated
that's to say so once you get past the
heart the facts don't matter as much and
our job from our point of view is to get
the facts out do our job tell the truth
follow the constitution follow the law
and defend the institutions
and the institutions held
let's take a look at what you were
competing with this is former the former
president speaking in georgia on
december 5th
evidence of fraud is overwhelming and
again i'm going to ask you to look up at
that very very powerful and very
expensive screen hidden cases of
possible ballots are rolled out from
under a table four people under a cloud
of suspicion
so
if you just take the crime
of what those democrats workers were
doing and by the way there was no water
main break you know they said there was
no border paper
that's ten times more than i need
to win this state ten times more
it's ten times maybe more than that but
it's 10 times more
because we lost by a very close number
this committee's hearing last monday we
heard from senior federal law
enforcement officials
from the senior most
federal law enforcement official in
atlanta at the time
u.s attorney for the northern district
b.j pack as well as former attorney
general bill barr
they both testified that the allegations
were thoroughly investigated and found
to have no merit here is u.s attorney
pac
it goes to attorney general i told him
that we looked into it we've done
several things including interviewing
the witnesses i listened to the
tapes and review the videotape myself
and that there was nothing there
giuliani was wrong and representative
was
too caseful of balance
and here's what attorney general bill
barr had to say about the same
allegations
took a look hard look at this ourselves
and based on our
uh review of it including the interviews
of the key witnesses
the fulton county uh
allegations were had no merit
we also have testimony from senior
department of justice officials
establishing
that they specifically told president
trump these allegations had been
thoroughly investigated and were
completely
without merit here is acting attorney
deputy attorney general richard donahue
describing a phone conversation in which
he specifically told president trump
that these allegations were false
i think kept fixating on this suitcase
that supposedly had cargo and pallets
that the suitcase was rolled out from
under the table
and i said no sir there is no suitcase
you can watch that video over and over
there is no suitcase there is a wheeled
bin
where they came
where they carry the ballots
no matter how many times senior
department of justice officials
including his own attorney general told
the president
that these allegations were not true
president trump kept promoting these
lies and putting pressure on state
officials to accept them
on january 2nd the president had a lenky
telephone conversation with secretary
raffensberger
prior to the president's call though i
want to share a bit of important context
first the white house
including the former president's chief
of staff
mark meadows
repeatedly called or texted the
secretary's office
some 18 times in order to set up this
call
they were quite persistent
second chief of staff mark meadows took
the extraordinary step of showing up at
a signature audit site in georgia
where he met with secretary
raffensberger's chief investigator
francis watson who was supervising that
audit process
behind me is a photograph from that
visit
third the day after meadows georgia
visit he set up a call between president
trump and francis watson
on the call between president trump and
georgia investigator francis watson the
former president continued to push the
false claim that he'd won the state of
georgia let's listen to that part of the
conversation
you know it's just you have the most
important job in the country right now
because if we win georgia first of all
if we win you're gonna have two wins
they're not gonna win right now you know
they're down
because
the people of georgia are so angry at
what happened to me they know i won i
want to buy hundreds of thousands of
votes it wasn't close
and in this next clip he told the state
law enforcement official that she'd be
praised
if she found
the right answer
hopefully
you know i will
when when the right answer comes out
you'd be praised i mean i don't know why
you know they
need it so hard
they will be praised people will say
great
because that's what it's about that
ability to check into
and to make it right because everyone
knows it's wrong there's
mr raffensberger i know you weren't on
this call but but that you have listened
to it
president trump didn't win by hundreds
of thousands of votes in georgia did he
no it did not
i've been traveling through the state of
georgia for a year now and
uh simply put in a nutshell
what happened in fall of 2020
is that 28 000 georgians skipped the
presidential race
and yet they voted down ballot in other
races and the republican congressmen
ended up getting 33 000 more votes than
president trump and that's why president
trump came up short
thank you mr secretary
the president on this call doesn't stop
here
let's listen to another part of the
conversation between president trump and
ms watson
anyway but whatever you can do francis
it would be it's a great thing it's an
important thing for the country he's so
important you have no idea it's so
important
i very much appreciate it
whatever you can do francis this is the
president of the united states
calling an investigator looking into the
election which he is a candidate and
asking her to do whatever you can do
mr secretary
you placed this call to your chief
investigator in september 23rd 2020. the
subcommittee has received text messages
indicating that mark meadows wanted to
send some of the investigators in her
office
in the words of one white house aide a
shitload of potus stuff including coins
actual autographed maga hats etc
white house staff intervened to make
sure that didn't happen
it was clear at the time of this call
that the former president had his sights
set on january 6th
listen to this portion when he told
francis watson about a very important
they'll be working date christmas and
keep it going fast because you know we
have that database which is a very
important date
an important date of course was the
joint session of congress where george's
electoral votes would be counted for joe
biden a little a little over a week
after this call to francis watson
the president was finally able to speak
with you secretary raffettsberger
bear in mind as we discussed this call
today that by this point in time early
january the election in georgia had
already been certified
but perhaps more important the president
of the united states had already been
told repeatedly by his own top justice
department officials that the claims he
was about to make to you about massive
fraud in georgia were completely false
mr secretary the call between you and
the president lasted 67 minutes over an
hour
we obviously can't listen to the entire
recording here today although it is
available on the select committee's
website
we'll listen to selected excerpts of it
now so that we can get your insights
let's begin with the president raising
the thoroughly debunked allegations
of suitcases of ballots
in an official voter box they were in
what looked to be
uh uh suitcases or trunks
suitcases but they weren't in uh
in voter boxes
uh the minimum number it could be
because we watched it and they they
watched it
certified
uh in slow motion
instant replay if you can believe it but
they had slow motion and it was
magnified many times over
and the minimum it was was 18 000
ballots all provided
these are the allegations that the
department of justice the attorney
general the georgia bureau of
investigation and your office had all
said
were false is that right
correct and even more importantly
when b.j pack resigned as u.s attorney
of the northern district
president trump appointed as acting u.s
attorney the northern district bobby
christine and bobby christine looked at
that and he was quoted the ajc that he
found nothing and he dismissed that case
early else
thank you mr secretary the president
references suitcases or trunks
uh mr sterling were the objects seen in
these videos suitcases or trunks or were
they just the ordinary containers that
are used by election workers understand
that standard ballot carriers that allow
for seals to be put on them so they're
tamper proof
and finally the president claims that
there was a minimum of 18 000 ballots
somehow smuggled in all for biden i take
it uh gentlemen that that was also
categorically false
there's no a there's no physical way he
could know who those ballots were for
but secondarily
we had
fulton county for years has been an
issue in our state when it comes to
elections so we had they had a very
difficult time during the primary in
large part because of cobit so we had
put them under a consent decree the
secretary got negotiated where we had a
monitor um on site and his name was
carter jones and he took a notation he
had gone from state farm to the english
street warehouse to look at the ocean
activities but before he left the state
farm arena he noted
how many vows have been counted on each
one of the machines
and when he
came back after we found out they were
working again
he took note again when they closed and
i believe the final number was something
around 8 900 total ballots were scanned
from the time he left to the time by 12
30 or 1 o'clock in the morning so way
below 18 000.
let's play the next clip
i heard it was close i said there's no
way
but they dropped a lot of votes in there
late at night you know that brad
mr secretary did somebody drop drop a
lot of votes there late at night
no
i believe that the president was
referring to some of the counties when
they would upload but the ballots had
all been accepted and had to be accepted
by state law by 7 pm so there were no
additional ballots accepted after 7pm
let's play the next clip in which the
president makes claims about so-called
dead voters
the other thing dead people
so dead people voted and i think uh the
the number is in the pro close to 5 000
people
and they went to uh obituaries they went
to all sorts of methods to come up with
an accurate number and a minimum is
close to about 5 000 voters
so secretary did your office investigate
whether those allegations were accurate
did
5 000 dead people in georgia vote
uh no it's not accurate actually in
their lawsuits they allege 10 315 dead
people
uh we found two dead people when i wrote
my letter to congress that stated
january 6 and subsequent to that we
found two more that's one two three four
people not four thousand but just a
total four not ten thousand not five
thousand
let's play the next clip
and there's nothing wrong with saying
that you know uh
that you've recalculated because
uh the 2000 236 and absentee ballots i
mean they're all exact
numbers that were were done by
accounting firms law firms etc
and even if you cut them in half cut
them in half and cut them in half again
it's more votes than we need
mr secretary is there any way that you
could have lawfully changed the result
in the state of georgia
and somehow explained it away as a
recalculation
the numbers are the numbers the numbers
don't lie
we had many allegations and we
investigated every single one of them
that i challenged my team did we miss
anything
they said that there was over 66 000
underage voters we found that there's
actually zero you can register to vote
in georgia when you're 17 and a half you
have to be 18 by election day we checked
that out every single voter they said
that there was 2423 non-registered
voters there was zero they said that
there was 2056 felons we identified less
than 74 or less that were actually still
in felony sentence every single
allegation we checked we ran down the
rabbit trail to make sure that our
numbers were accurate
so there's no way you could have
recalculated except uh by fudging the
numbers
the numbers were the numbers and we
could not recalculate because we had
made sure that we had checked every
single allegation
we had many investigations we had nearly
300 from the 2020 election
mr secretary you tried to push back when
the president made these unsupported
claims whether they were about suitcases
of ballots
or that biden votes were counted three
times let's play the next
clip accident they did not put that we
we can we did an audit of that and we
proved conclusively that they were not
scanned three times yep mr president
we'll send you the link from wsb that
doesn't i don't care about a link i
don't need it i have a much better
you told the president you would send
him a link from wsb which i understand
is a local television station that had
a uh unedited video from the state farm
arena but the president wasn't
interested in that he said he had a much
better link
mr secretary
at the time that you were on the call
with the president as we have shown both
the fbi and the georgia bureau
investigation
have proven these claims to be nonsense
and you told him about these
investigations on the phone let's listen
to what president trump had to say about
the state and federal law enforcement
officers
who conducted who investigated these
false claims
there's no way they could then they're
incompetent
they're either dishonest they're fine
it's okay there's only two answers
dishonesty or incompetence this is no
way look there's no way
but the president didn't stop at
insinuating that law enforcement
officers were either dishonest or
incompetent
he went on to suggest that you could be
subject to criminal liability for your
role in the matter
before i play that portion of the
conversation i'd like to show you
something that the president retweeted a
couple weeks before your call with him
here's the president retweeting a post
from one of his allies
a lawyer who was later sanctioned by a
judge in michigan for making false
claims of election fraud
let's take a look at that tweet
the tweet read quote president trump at
real donald trump is a genuinely good
man he does not really like to fire
people i bet he dislikes putting people
in jail especially quote unquote
republicans
he gave at brian kemp georgia and at
georgia secretary of state every chance
to get it right
they refused they will soon be going to
jail
so on your call this was not the first
time the president was suggesting you
might be criminally liable with that
let's listen to this portion of the call
i think you're going to find that they
are shredding ballots because they have
to get rid of the ballots because the
ballots are unsigned the ballots are are
[Music]
corrupt
and they're brand new and they don't
have seals and there's a whole thing
with the ballots but the ballots are
corrupt and you're going to find that
they are which is totally illegal it's
it's it's more illegal for you than it
is for them because you know what they
did and you're not reporting it that's
that you know that's a criminal that's a
criminal offense
and and you know you can't let that
happen that's that's a big risk to you
and to ryan
your lawyer that's a big risk
secretary robertsburg after making a
false claim about shredding a ballots
the president suggested
that you may be committing a crime by
not going along with his claims of
election fraud
and after suggesting that you might have
criminal exposure
president trump makes his most explicit
ask
of the call
let's play a part of that conversation
so look all i want to do is this i just
want to find
uh
11
780
votes which is one more that we have
because we won the state
mr secretary was the president here
asking you for exactly what he wanted
one more vote than his opponent
what i knew is that we didn't have any
votes to find we had continued to look
we investigated like i just shared the
numbers with you there were no votes to
find that was an accurate count that had
been certified
and as our general counsel said there
was no shredding of ballots
mr secretary after making this request
the president then goes back to the
danger of having you deny these
allegations of fraud let's listen to
that part of the clip
and i watched you this morning and you
said uh
well there was no criminality but i i
mean all of this stuff is is very
dangerous stuff when you talk about no
criminality i think it's very dangerous
for you to say that
secretary robertsburger you wrote about
this in your book
and you said quote
i felt then and still believed today
that this was a threat
others obviously thought so too
because some of trump's more radical
followers have responded as if it was
their duty to carry out this threat
please tell us what you your wife even
your daughter-in-law experienced
regarding threats from trump's more
radical followers
well after the
after the election
uh
my
email my cell phone was doxxed and so i
was getting texts all over the country
and then eventually my wife started
getting the text and hers typically came
in as sexualized attacks which were
disgusting you have to understand that
trish and i we met in high school we
were married over 40 years now and so um
they started going after her i think
just to
probably put pressure on me why'd you
just quit walk away
and so that happened
and then some people broke into my
daughter-in-law's home and uh my son has
passed and she's a widow
and she has two kids and so we're very
concerned about her safety also
mr secretary why didn't you just quit
and walk away
because i knew that we had followed the
law and we followed the constitution
and i think sometimes moments require
you to stand up
and just take the shots you're doing
your job and that's all we did
you know we just followed the loan we
followed the constitution
and at the end of the day president came
up short but i had to be faithful to the
constitution
and that's what i saw an oath to do
during the remainder of the call the
former president continued to press you
to find the remaining votes that would
ensure his victory in georgia let's
listen to a little more
why wouldn't you want to find the right
answer brad instead of keep saying that
the numbers are right
so look uh can you get together and brad
we just want the truth it's simple
and uh
and everyone's gonna look very good if
the truth comes out it's okay it takes a
little while but let the truth come out
and the truth the real truth is i won by
400 000 votes at least
so
so what are we going to do here about i
only need 11 000 votes fellas i need 11
000 votes give me a break
four days after the president's call to
secretary raffensenberger was january
6th
the president whipped up the crowd in
front of the ellipse once again
promoting the allegation
that secretary raffertsburger
president's own attorney general
told him was false
here he is on the ellipse
in fulton county republican paul
watchers were ejected in some cases
physically
from the room under the false pretense
of a pipe first water main birth
everybody leave which we now know was a
total lie
then
election officials full boxes democrats
and suitcases of ballots out from under
a table you all saw it on television
totally fraudulent and illegally scanned
them for nearly two hours totally
unsupervised
tens of thousands of votes this act
coincided with a mysterious vote dump
of up to 100 000 votes for joe biden
almost none for trump oh that sounds
fair
that was at 1 34 a.m
mr secretary mr sterling i want to thank
you for your service to the state of
georgia and to the country
um speaker bowers likewise i want to
thank you for your service to the state
of arizona and to the country you have
served not only your home states
but our nation and our democracy
mr chairman i yield back
thank you mr schiff i thank the
witnesses for joining us today
you're now dismissed
foreign
i'm not sure if we'll be taking a break
here but we're going to watch the
witnesses leave the hearing room
as we presume the hearing they have not
gaveled out for break
we will see if they bring in panel two
shea moss
a former
georgia election worker looks like shea
is coming in now
to
take her place at the witness table to
be sworn in
to give her testimony
in day four
of the january six
select public hearing
let's go
back to the hearing
i now welcome our found witness this
afternoon
andrea shea moss
miss moss worked in the department of
registration and elections in fulton
county georgia
from 2017 until 2022
in that job ms moss handled voter
applications and absentee ballot
requests
and also helped to process the vote
count for several elections
in december 2020 miss moss and her
mother
miss ruby freeman became the target of
nasty lies spread by president trump and
his allies as they sought to overturn
the election results in georgia
miss moss and her mother miss freeman
are two of the unsung heroes in this
country
doing the hard work of keeping our
democracy functioning for every
american miss moss welcome
thank you for your service and i thank
you for being here today
uh i will now swear in please stand
do you swear are affirmed on the penalty
of perjury that the testimony you're
about to give is the truth the whole
truth and nothing but the truth so help
you god
thank you please be seated
let the record reflect that the witness
answered in the affirmative
miss walk miss moss thank you very much
for being here today
i understand that you are here
along with your mother today
uh would you like to introduce your mama
hi mom
uh miss moss
today we'll be asking you about some of
the threats that you receive following
the 2020 election
since you've been an election worker for
over 10 years
i want to ask you
in your decade of service
have you ever experienced threats like
these before
uh
don't be nervous just
i understand
so
uh and
i want to make sure that the record
reflects that you've done it
for quite a while and you never received
a threat and your answer was no
thank you
pursuant to section 5c8 of the house
resolution five zero three
the chair recognizes the gentleman from
california was to shift for questions
good afternoon ms moss uh thank you for
being here i understand that you were
employed by the fulton county
registration and elections department
for more than 10 years
and i understand that you love that job
please tell us what made you so fond of
the work that you did
um
well
i've always
been told by my grandmother how
important it is of a vote and how
people before me a lot of people um
older people my family did not have that
right
so
what i loved most
um about my job were the older voters um
younger people could usually do
everything from their phone or go online
but
the older voters like to call they like
to talk to you they like to get my card
they like to know that every election
i'm here
um
and like even college students a lot of
parents um
trust in me to make sure their child
does not have to drive home
they'll get an absentee ballot they can
vote and i really found pleasure in that
i like being the one that
um
you know if someone can't navigate
my voter page or you know they want a
new precinct card and they don't have a
copy machine or computer or all of that
i could put it in the mail for them
i was excited always about sending out
all the absentee ballots for the elderly
disabled people
i even remember driving to an
hospital
to
give someone her absentee application um
that's that's what i love the most
so you really enjoyed helping people
vote and participate and
uh and that was something
the right to vote that your grandmother
taught you was precious yeah
well i know the events that we're here
to talk about today are incredibly
difficult to relive
your proud service as an election worker
took a dramatic turn on the day that
rudy giuliani publicized a video
of you and your mother counting ballots
on election night
president trump rudy giuliani and others
claimed on the basis of this video that
you and your mother were somehow
involved in a plot
to kick out observers bring suitcases of
false ballots for biden into the arena
and then run them through the machines
multiple times
none of that was true was it
none of it
i'd like to show you some of the
statements that rudy giuliani made in a
second hearing before the georgia state
legislators
a week after that video clip from state
farm arena was first circulated
by mr giuliani and president trump
i want to advise viewers that these
statements are completely false
and also deeply disturbing
tape earlier in the day
of ruby freeman and shea freeman morris
and one other gentleman
quite obviously surreptitiously passing
around
usb ports assist their vials of heroin
or cocaine
i mean it's our st it's obvious to
anyone who's a criminal investigator or
prosecutor they are engaged in
serviticious illegal activity again that
day and that's a week ago
and they're still walking around georgia
lying
should have been they should have been
uh
she'd been questioned already
their places of work their homes should
have been searched for evidence of
balance trail
evidence of usb ports
to evidence of voter fraud
that video was from rudy giuliani's
appearance at a georgia state senate
hearing on december 10.
how did you become aware how did you
first become aware that rudy giuliani
president's lawyer was accusing you and
your mother of a crime
i was at work like always um
and
the former
chief mr jones asked me to come to his
office and
um when i went to his office
the former director mr barron was in
there
and
they showed me a video
on their computer
um
it was just like a very short clip of
us working at state farm and it had
someone on the video like
talking
um
over the video just saying that we were
doing things that we
weren't supposed to do just
lying um
throughout the video
and that's when i first found out about
it
and were there social media posts uh
that they showed you
responding to those false claims
well um
when when i saw the video of course the
first thing that i said was like why
what why is why are they doing this
what's going on
and um they you know just told me that
trump and his allies were not
satisfied with the outcome of the
election
and
they they were getting a lot of threats
and
um
being harassed online and asked me you
know have i been receiving anything and
i need to check on my mom
and
i told them um you know i was like
where where have they
you know where have you been getting
these threats i
don't believe i have any and um mr jones
told me like they're attacking his
uh facebook and i don't really use
facebook i have one so i went to the
facebook app and i'm just kind of
panicky at this point because this has
never happened to me and my mom is
involved i'm like her only child
so i'm just asking him like where are
the messages all i see is the fees like
how do you get to the messages and he
said it's another
icon on your phone that says messenger
and i went to that icon and
it was just a lot of horrible things
there
and those horrible things that they
include threats
yes a lot of threats um
wishing death upon me um
telling me that you know i'm i'll be in
jail with my mother and
saying things like
be glad it's 2020 and not 1920.
that's
yeah
were a lot of these threats and and vile
comments racist in nature
a lot of them were racist a lot of them
were just hateful
um yes sir
one of the videos we just watched mr
giuliani accused you and your mother are
passing some sort of usb drive
to each other uh what was your mom
actually handing you on that video
a gender mate
it wasn't just rudy giuliani
we heard president trump make these
false allegations
repeatedly during his call with
secretary raffensberger
let's listen to
a portion of what he had to say about
you and your mother
we had
at least 18 000 that's on tape we had
them counted
very
secondly 18 000 voters
uh having to do with ruby freeman that's
she's a vote scammer a professional vote
scammer and hustler
donald trump attacked you and your
mother using her name 18 times on that
call
18 times
mr moss can you describe what you
experienced listening to former
president trump attack you and your
mother
in a call with the georgia secretary of
state
i felt horrible
i felt like it was all my fault like if
i would have never decided to be an
elections worker like
i could have on anything else but that's
what i decided to do and now
people are lying and spreading rumors
and lies and attacking my mom
my only child
going to my grandmother's house her only
grandchild
and
and my kid it's just
i
felt so bad i just felt bad for my mom
and i felt
horrible for picking this job and being
the one that always wants to help and
always there
never missing out one election i just
felt like it was it was my fault for
putting my family in this situation
well it wasn't your fault
uh your mother was kind enough to come
speak with us earlier let's listen to
her story and her words
my name is ruby freeman
i've always believed that when god says
that he'll make your name great
but
this is not the way it was supposed to
be
i
could have never imagined the events
that followed the presidential election
2020.
for my entire professional life i was
lady ruby
my community in georgia
where i was born and lived my whole life
knew me as lady ruby
i built my own business
around that name the ruby's unique
treasures
a pop-up shop catering to ladies with
unique fashions
i wore a shirt that proudly proclaimed
that i was
and i am
lady ruby
actually i had that shirt on
i had that shirt in every color
i wore that shirt on election day 2020
i haven't worn it since
and i'll never wear it again
now i won't even introduce my
self by my name anymore
i get nervous when i bump into someone
i know in the grocery store who says my
name
i'm worried about
who's listening
i get nervous when i have to give my
name for food orders
i'm always concerned of who's around me
i've lost my name and i've lost my
reputation
i've lost my sense of security
all because a group of people starting
with number 45
and his ally rudy giuliani decided to
escape goat me and my daughter shake
to push their own lies about how the
presidential election was stolen
moss how is this experience of being
targeted by the former president and his
allies affected your life
this time my life
upside down um
i no longer give out my business card
i don't transfer calls
i um
i don't want anyone knowing my name
i don't want to go anywhere with my mom
because she might yell my name out over
the grocery aisle or something
i don't go to the grocery store at all
i haven't been
anywhere um
at all
i gained about 60 pounds i just
don't do nothing anymore i don't want to
go anywhere i second guess
everything that i do
[Music]
um
it's affecting my life in a major way
in every way
all because of lies
for me doing my job same thing i've been
doing forever
your mother also told us the committee
about how she had to leave her own home
for her safety and go into hiding
after the fbi told her that it would not
be safe for her there before january 6th
and until the inauguration let's listen
to a clip of her story in her own words
around the week of
january 6th
the fbi
informed me that i needed to leave my
home for safety
um
and i left my home for safety around
that time
i understood how long did you stay how
did you you know remain outside of your
home for your own safety
i i stayed away from my home for
approximately two months
it was horrible i felt homeless i felt
you know
i can't believe i can't believe this
person has caused this much damage to me
and my family
to have to leave my home
that i've lived there for 21 years
and you know i'm having to have my
neighbors watch out for me
[Music]
you know
and i have to go and stay with somebody
it was hard it was horrible
and that um your conversation with the
fbi about needing to leave your home for
your only thing you were recommending it
do you remember was there a specific
threat that prompted that or was it the
accumulation of
expression
what prompted it was um
was getting ready to
january 6
was about to come
and
they did not want me to be at home
because of all the threats and
everything that i had gotten they didn't
want
me to be there in fear of you know the
people would come into my home and
i had a lot of that
so they didn't want me to be there just
in case something happened i asked how
long am i gonna have to be at home they
said at least until the inauguration
mrs moss i understand that people once
showed up at your grandmother's house
tell us about that experience
um
i received a call from my grandmother
this
woman is my everything i've never even
heard her or seen her cry
ever in my life and um
she called me
screaming at the top of her lungs like
shay shay oh my gosh shane just
freaking me out
saying that um
there were people at her home
and they um you know they knocked on the
door and of course she opened it seeing
who was there who it was and they just
started
pushing their way through
claiming that they were coming in
to make a citizen's arrest
they needed to find me and my mom they
knew we were there
um
and
[Music]
she was just
screaming and didn't know what to do and
i wasn't
there so you know
i just felt so helpless and so horrible
for her
and she um
was just screaming i told her to close
the door don't open the door for anyone
and um
you know she's a 70 something i won't
say a year old woman and she
she doesn't like
having restrictions she wants to answer
the door she likes to get her steps in
walking around the neighborhood
i had to tell her like you can't do that
you have to be safe um
you know she would tell me that
at night
um people would just continuously send
pizzas over and over to her home um you
know and they was expecting her to pay
for these large amounts of pizzas and
she went through a lot that she didn't
have to once again it made me just
feel so horrible
in addition to the personal impact this
experience has had on you and your
family
one of the things that i find most
disturbing
is how these lies discourage long-time
election workers from continuing to do
this important work
tell us if you would of the other
election workers shown in that state
farm arena video and their supervisors
how many are still election workers in
fulton county
um
there is no permanent
election worker or supervisor
in that video that's still there
and did you end up leaving you're
leaving your position as well
yes i i left
ms moss i want to thank you for coming
to speak with us
and thank you for your service
to our democracy
what we have just played is a truly
horrible and appalling sample
but just a sample of the things that
were said about you and your mother
following the election
i want to say how very
sorry i think we all are for what you've
gone through
and tragically you're not alone
other election workers around the
country have also been the subject of
lies and threats
no election workers should be subject to
such heinous treatment just for doing
their job
with your permission i would like to
give your mother the last word
yes
we're just going to play the tape
there is nowhere i feel safe
nowhere
do you know how it feels to have
the president of the united states to
target you
the president of the united states is
supposed to represent every american
not to target one
but he targeted me
lady rudy
a small business owner a mother a proud
american citizen
who stand up
to help fulton county run an election in
the middle of the pandemic
thank you ms moss
thank you miss freeman or as
america now knows her lady ruby
for your service to fulton county
georgia our country and our democracy
mr chairman i yield back
thank you mr
chef
miss moss
i want to thank you for sharing with us
the very troubling story of what you and
your mother experience
the harassment of election workers like
you simply for doing your duty as public
servants
poses a threat to our democratic process
your testimony is an important
contribution to the work of our
committee
and serves as a reminder to all of us
that the safety of local election
officials is vital to ensuring that our
elections
are always
free and fair
i want to thank our witness for joining
us today
the members of the select committee may
have additional questions for today's
witness
and we ask
that you respond expeditiously in
writing to those questions
without objection members will be
permitted 10 business days to submit
statements for the record including
opening remarks and additional questions
for the witness
without objection the chair recognizes
the gentleman from california must shift
for a closing statement
for more than 200 years our democracy
has been distinguished by the peaceful
transfer of power
when an american raises their right hand
and takes the presidential oath of
office
they are transformed from an ordinary
citizen
into the most powerful person in the
world
the president
this is an awesome pirate power to
acquire
it is even more awesome when is handed
on peacefully
when george washington relinquished the
office of the presidency it set a
precedent that served as a beacon
for other nations struggling against
tyranny
when ronald reagan described it as a
kind of miracle in the eyes of the world
he was exactly right
other countries use violence to seize
and hold power
but not in the united states
not in america
when donald trump used the power of the
presidency to try to stay in office
after losing the election to joe biden
he broke that sacred and centuries-old
covenant
whether his actions were criminal will
ultimately be for others to decide
but what he did was without a doubt
unconstitutional
it was unpatriotic
and it was fundamentally
unamerican
and when he used the power of his
presidency to put the enormous pressure
on state local and local elections
officials and his own vice president
it became downright dangerous
on january 6th that pressure became
deadly
ruby freeman said the president is
supposed to protect every american not
target them
and she is right
if the most powerful person in the world
can bring the full weight of the
presidency down on an ordinary citizen
who is merely doing her job
with a lie as big and heavy as a
mountain
who among us is safe
none of us is
none of us
in city councils and town councils
on school boards and election boards
from the congress to the courts
dedicated public servants are leaving
their posts because of death threats
to them
and to their families
this is not who we are
it must not become who we are
our democracy held because courageous
people like those you heard from today
put their oath
to the constitution
above their loyalty to one man or to one
party
the system held but barely and the
question remains will it hold again
if we are able to communicate anything
during these hearings i hope it is this
we have been blessed beyond measured to
live in the world's greatest democracy
that is a legacy to be proud of and to
cherish
but it is not one to be taken for
granted
that we have lived in a democracy for
more than 200 years does not mean we
shall do so tomorrow
we must reject violence we must embrace
our constitution with the reverence it
deserves
take our oath of office and duties as
citizens seriously
informed by the knowledge of right and
wrong and armed
with no more than the power of our ideas
and the truth carry on this venerable
experiment
in self-governance
thank you mr chairman and i yield back
without objection the chair recognized
the gentlewoman from
ms cheney for a closing statement
thank you very much mr chairman
lady ruby and shay thank you for your
courage thank you for your strength
thank you for for being here today it it
means so much for everyone to hear your
story so thank you for that
um we have had tremendous uh testimony
today we've been reminded that we're a
nation of laws and we've been reminded
by you uh and by speaker bowers and
secretary of state raffensberger mr
sterling that our institutions don't
defend themselves individuals do that
and we reminded that
it takes public servants it takes people
who've made a commitment to our system
to defend our system
we also have been reminded what it means
to take an oath under god to the
constitution
uh what it means to defend the
constitution
and we were reminded by speaker bowers
that our constitution is indeed a
divinely inspired document
and so it's been an honor to spend time
with you and with our previous witnesses
here today
to date more than 30 witnesses called
before this committee
have not done what you've done but have
invoked their fifth amendment rights
against self-incrimination
roger stone took the fifth general
michael flynn took the fifth john
eastman took the fifth
others like steve bannon and peter
navarro simply refused to comply with
lawful subpoenas and they have been
indicted
mark meadows has hidden behind president
trump's claims of executive privilege
and immunity from subpoenas
we're engaged now in litigation with mr
meadows
the american people in our hearings have
heard from bill barr jeff rosen richard
donahue and many others who stood up and
did what is right
and they will hear more of that
testimony soon but the american people
have not yet heard from mr trump's
former white house counsel pat sipoloni
our committee is certain that donald
trump does not want mr sipoloni to
testify here
indeed our evidence shows that mr
sipoloni and his office tried to do what
was right they tried to stop a number of
president trump's plans for january 6.
today and in our coming hearings you
will hear testimony from other trump
white house staff
explaining what mr sipoloni said and did
including on january 6th
but we think the american people deserve
to hear from mr sipoloni personally he
should appear before this committee and
we are working to secure his testimony
thank you mr chairman i yield back
people answered a call to public service
in such different ways
some run for office
some volunteer to make sure that
neighbors can get
to their voting locations
some work at polling sites to help
election day go smoothly
some look into problems to guarantee our
elections are secure and accurate
just to name a few
as i mentioned at the start of this
hearing
when we talk about our democratic
institutions
we're talking about
these individuals and many others who do
these jobs across the country
they represent the backbone of our
democracy
at its most important moments when the
citizens cast their votes
and when those votes are counted
we've heard the stories of their courage
they've earned the thanks of a grateful
nation
but for donald trump
these witnesses and others like them
were another roadblock to his attempt
to cling to power
on thursday we'll hear about another
part of that scheme
his attempt to corrupt the country's top
law enforcement body
the justice department to support his
attempt to overturn the election
just as we heard today
that donald trump was deeply involved in
the scheme to pressure state officials
to overturn the election results
we're here we will hear on thursday that
donald trump
was also the driving force behind the
effort to corrupt the justice department
listen to this clip
from the former acting attorney general
richard donahue
the president says suppose i do this
suppose i replace
jeff rosen
with him jeff clark
what do you do
and i said sir i would resign
immediately there is no way i'm serving
one minute under this guy jeff clark
you'll hear from mr donahue in person on
thursday
as my colleague mr kenzinger presents
details about this plan
the chair requests those in the hearing
room remain seated
until the capitol police have escorted
members from the room
without objection the committee stands
adjoined
as we watch the gavel go down in the day
four
of the january six select public
hearings
there is a great dismount here
from
representative liz cheney against her
republican colleagues who will not are
who have refused to testify
i'm calling them out by name
and then chairman thompson
giving a preview
of what will be to come on thursday
remember
stay with the midas touch media network
here we are going to bring you a panel
of commentary
as soon as we watch the members leave
and also join us on thursday here on the
midas media network subscribe to midas
touch youtube channel
you will find the link
later this afternoon or this evening for
the hearing on thursday
the gavel is scheduled to go down at 3
p.m eastern time we will start our
coverage an hour early just as we have
done with every hearing prior
so we will start on thursday at 2 p.m
eastern time
with hearing
day number five i want to bring in
a couple people here from our panel
uh jessica denson
jessica is the
known as the trump nda killer she went
against trump
and won and got his
nda invalidated i want to bring her in
and see if she can comment with me
on liz cheney's comments at the end her
closing statement where she pointed out
by name
the
members of her party jessica what did
you make of liz cheney's final
statements there
i think they were very pointed towards
her republican colleagues um i know you
you've been in this world before with
trump and some of his allies and going
against them what did you make of that
statement by liz cheney there
yeah you can
be patient with me i'm a little bit
worked up from what we just saw it it
hit very close to home to say to say it
lightly
um
what it what i made of liz cheney's
comments is that
those individuals that she she called
out
are going to go down in history as
cowards
as the most unpatriotic
um
unfaithful
uh
just complete lack of character
americans that we have ever seen in
so-called public service and you know
who will replace them as real heroes as
the real ones who stood for democracy
jay moss ruby freeman these women who
who whose names have been slandered and
whose lives have been turned upside down
these women
are the heroes
in
that we will
remember in history and pat sipoloni and
whoever else decides not to come before
this committee and speak
shame on them
i i am
connected so much to these two women um
i am also the daughter of a single
mother and i was terrorized by the trump
campaign while i was delusional about
who he represented and thought he
actually stood for something real
something good and i worked for these
terrorists and when i came into the
human resources department and told how
my personal laptop was being threatened
to be stolen from me two thousand miles
away by my former boss and my name was
being slandered and i was being accused
of leaking trump's taxes and shopping
bids to the media and i was a woman
terrorized in the workplace you know the
only thing that these people cared about
i heard about two things one did i have
money and was i connected
and
yeah those two things who who was i and
did i have any connections or power what
they surmised in their limited small
materialistic
viewpoint as power
and because i didn't
have power what they recognized as power
little did they know the power that i
really have
i was
thrown under the bus i was further
terrorized and then even when i spoke up
for my rights in challenging that nda
when they came after me for 1.5 million
dollars for exercising my legal rights
in a court of law they terrorized me all
over again they called me political i
literally was taking actions to save my
own life to have meaning in the world to
have a purpose and i was terrorized all
over again during the trump
administration my behavior was called
political by the most political entity
in the world the trump campaign
please let us recognize this gaslighting
the destruction that it has caused to so
many lives this the bible let me go back
to the bible it says you cannot pour out
from the same fountain sweet water and
bitter this is a corrupt dangerous
entity led by a corrupt dangerous man
and for the good of the world this man
must be prosecuted now we cannot allow
this terrorist to be a free man
indoctrinating the american people
anymore
god
i can see that the
the testimony from
miss moss there and also the video
testimony from the panel
uh brings back memories of
the trump administration the trump
campaign
what they do to someone like you said
who is powerless especially
women we see that as a pattern
from trump and his allies that what they
did to this
poor miss moss and her mother and even
her grandmother
as they outed them as they docked them
as they turned their mob to them um
one would say
absolutely
absolutely criminal
um i'd like to bring in
karen
nivolo here
if i can to speak on that because i
believe uh through the testimony karen
did a little bit of research on miss
moss um karen can you tell us a little
bit about what you found
um
[Music]
yeah i still got an echo for me there
karen um if you could speak to the
the actual
lawsuit that is happening
where miss moss is suing not only oan
but also rudy giuliani because rudy
giuliani made some very very
what seemed to be defamatory statements
against miss moss and her family
can you speak to what you found
sure is it
uh your mic doesn't seem to be working
properly
let me see if i can bring in david
bender to see what he made of the
testimony david are you there i am
uh
the thing first off
jessica i
i feel for you and and
how this must be
a trigger
to hear
this and to relive it and
realize that what we're seeing with uh
lady ruby and and
shea moss is
is playing out all over the country and
it's still playing out and you're so
right this has to stop it has to stop
right now
and
i i hope people are listening to what
you've said and i want to i want to
congratulate you because you stood up
and you fought that fight and you
took this on and you won
which is a very
very rare thing to have done
so
that that gives
hope and encouragement to a lot of other
people including
shay moss in the lawsuit she's filing
right now
to know that it is possible to stand up
to
a
person who will use power
only for
his own game
he cares the the most telling line was
the president is supposed to care about
every american
that president cared about only one
american
not even members of his own family
and and we now understand that but
i think what's so important and why it's
important
that
your reaction
and
their reaction today you saw how
terrified
sheamos was at the beginning how hard
that was for her to do
the reason is they're not sure what's
going to happen next what's going to
happen to brad raffensberger who just
won
essentially renomination maybe
re-election but he's going to go back
and the same thing will happen to
him and his wife of 40 years
these things have not gone away
and
i i
remember at
the last
conversation with texas paul how angry
he was
i'm angry too but i'm i'm very focused
we cannot let our anger stop us from
making this
happen
and these hearings today i i think and
tony i i i wonder if you
share my view
i think this was the most powerful of
all the hearings we've seen so far
this had the greatest impact i i i i
have that feeling um i knew today would
be powerful because
we have the video of
the
chief
operating officer gabriel sterling gabe
sterling
from that moment in time where he's
saying someone's going to get killed
and then on january 6 we seen violence
ensued and someone get killed and then
today
i haven't heard the story of miss moss
and lady ruby i hadn't heard that full
story i know
that that story existed and i and i may
have misspoke a little earlier i thought
uh because i knew one of them was a
volunteer but apparently lady ruby was a
volunteer right um and miss moss even
said she felt like that it was her fault
that these people were attacking her
family her mother who was a volunteer
who was just helping her
was just they were doing their civic
duty that they thought was part of the
american way and part of that fabric
of america and i i really
i think to walk through
not only the the
arizona house speaker the pressure that
was put there but the pressure that was
put on the secretary of state and his
chief operating officer which those
three
are elected and appointed politicians
through the electorate
but this sheamus and her mother
were not elected they were not appointed
by the people they were serving under
their their own
their own volition and they were trying
trying to be real true americans what
they felt like they could give back and
you even heard
ms moss say in so many words that she
regretted that
she even was an election worker because
she felt like she did this to her family
and i and i know jessica can probably
speak much more now passionately about
this because she's been attacked in this
way um but
what what a
what a story to be told today where we
see
that it wasn't just election officials
that they were pressuring
they were trying to make up any story
that they could to get anyone to say
anyone even even an election worker like
sheamos to say yes we they he was
cheated he was cheated and he won
and he and biden lost they were looking
for any person anyone absolutely anyone
to say that
um
i have a couple other guests here i
think karen's back i've got texas paul i
also have a special guest hal sparks
here with us um and my co-host um gabe
sanchez i think i'm gonna bring the
panel in um because i want karen to
speak on before we had some mic trouble
there karen how is your mic
there hopefully it's resolved does that
matter great we yes we got we got your
technical issues without we're going to
bring everybody in look look there's hal
with the thumbs up hi david bender
welcome
i know those thumbs and i know where
they've been it's true absolutely
there's plenty of video record um good
to see you
yeah well karen karen tell us now that
now that gabe's got your microphone
going there i know we had to put you in
another room to make sure it was working
um tell us what your thoughts were on
some of that last testimony um and and
really
go beyond i know jessica gave us the
emotional feel of it of what america
should feel in this moment
but tell us about the what you found
during her testimony about not only the
the actual threats but there was
there's been some lawsuits over those
threats
yeah so as everyone knows there's two
ways uh that this could be handled one
is criminal one is civil civil is when a
private citizen brings an action against
somebody for something like in this
particular instance defamation that's
what um that's what sheamos uh did here
and brought a suit against rudy giuliani
for defamation as well as the one
america network uh that i guess aired
these it's a i'm not it's sort of a
cable network for that right-wing cable
network yeah we call them trader tv
networks here yeah well whatever it is
you know it's i've actually never seen
it so
um and so they
uh she brought a defamation suit against
them
and the one against the network has
settled the one against rudy giuliani it
appears has been uh has continued and
does continue but the settlement was not
um published in terms of what the terms
was and how they settled it so i don't
know anything about it but you know what
strikes me about that
is
government and and law enforcement
they're there supposedly to protect you
why does a private citizen have to do it
themselves why did they have to be the
ones to go to court hire a lawyer and
and do this when when that's really what
law enforcement is there to do is to
protect you and when i was hearing the
stories that she told and what happened
to her that this this absolutely if it
was anybody else would have had would
have handcuffs on them and they'd be put
in prison i mean that is just outright
bullying to the point where it's
criminal and i just don't understand how
it is that we just allow we sit back and
allow these people to be you know the
former president of the united states
there is no person with a bigger bully
pulpit than donald trump and with more
power than he has and you know doxing we
use the word doxing as if that's normal
you know doxing is criminal doxxing is
publishing personal information online
for the purpose of harassment that's
what you do you know to get someone to
be harassed it's it's it's bullying
times a thousand right it's suddenly
it's not just someone in the schoolyard
it's it's every follower of the
president now can can have access to
these individuals and bully them it's
it's literally like pointing a weapon at
somebody and destroying their life if
there was ever a situation where it
called for criminal prosecution in my
opinion
this is it but once again he just nobody
will take the the
you know frankly have the balls to go
forward and bring a case against this
guy but they have to it is time how many
more things do we have to see
you know of what donald trump and his
cronies have done to people you know
jessica you are a hero that you have the
courage to come forward and say the
things that you did and fight this fight
somebody else someone who's
who's not emotionally involved because
they're the victim of these crimes i.e
the department of justice or local
prosecutors somebody has to finally have
the balls to take this man to court and
put the handcuffs on because this is
outrageous what else do we have to see
he bullies you know he interferes with
the election process in all these
different states we heard what he did in
georgia we heard what he did you know
in seven different states we heard it
now what he did to people to election
workers right these are just average
normal regular
hero people who you know it's their
civic duty to have a job to do this and
you allow the president to do what he
did to her to dox her i mean come on
i'm gonna go to adam's shift here
because he's saying almost the exact
same you're saying
let's listen into adam's shift here for
a second
uh you know i'm not going to comment on
uh potential future witnesses at this
point um i want to keep the focus uh on
what we just heard today
you know i'll have to make this last
question um look our responsibility at
the end of the day
is not a prosecutorial responsibility
that's for the justice department to
decide
uh i think judge carter in california
was right
when he said that there is evidence that
donald trump and his associates
engaged in a plot to overturn the
election that violated multiple criminal
laws
um i think there's sufficient evidence
to open that investigation now whether
the justice department will conclude
there's proof beyond a reasonable doubt
that'll be up to the justice department
our role is different our role is to
find the facts to share them with the
american people and to prescribe
remedies to keep our country safe
and as we saw today
one of the things that's necessary for
us to keep the country safe is to put
this big lie to rest
uh to restore people's confidence in our
elections
uh to push back on the idea that
whenever you lose an election that's
somehow rigged and illegitimate because
that way goes the end of our democracy
thank you thank you
and there is uh
representative adam schiff who did
a lot of the questioning today how hal
sparks um give us your um give us your
take on the testimony today what did you
what did you find most interesting about
the testimonials
but it was interesting that it was
bookended as being completely
heartbreaking because
nobody i think would be surprised that
we all felt for shay moss and her mother
and her grandmother rather and the and
the pressure they were put on and like
especially when you watch that video of
her meeting with kanye's publicist where
they're two days before gen 6 they're
putting extra pressure on them i think
most of us who've been following this
all along i've on my live stream i've
debunked all of mike lindell's movies
all of rudy giuliani's caring of this
live on his podcast and so i've seen
them tell these lies far more than they
showed today this is not like there are
three or four videos of rudy giuliani
saying this stuff he said it for months
every time somebody put a mic in front
of his face and endangered these
people's lives so i think i think people
were prepared to some degree to feel
sympathy for and and you know be upset
about that i think the surprising part
was bowers to some degree
in that you've got this arizona
republican that i don't necessarily ever
anybody you know ship wouldn't certainly
consider this guy to be on the team this
is a guy who was you know who voted for
trump in 2020 who arguably had this
stuff not happened would have given him
another shot in 2024 if he hadn't
carried this big lie and and looking at
that and looking how he teared up and
you know i i knew trump and and and
giuliani were in trouble when in in this
guy's testimony when he said they called
me right as my wife and i were returning
from church and the way he said it you
could tell like he and his wife do this
this is for real to them this is not the
kind of like you know poser
flashpoint
um you know
mega church nonsense that trump usually
gravitates to these are people of you
know of sort of
regular republican conservative faith
and this is he he just does not have the
button with these folks and that was the
i think the most surprising and and sort
of
reassuring thing in all of this
that that there are those that those
people still exist to some degree
and and that they're still not on team
trump and they won't be going forward
even though he had them in the palm of
sandy it it was his
election to lose with these folks next
in 2024 which he's not going to run for
the record that's garbage he's falling
apart but the i mean it's nonsense
the one thing i would like to remind
everyone to take a moment of joy
especially in listening to recordings of
him talking to ravensburger that this
insurrection however serious in the
moment on the capitol steps and in the
building itself was run top to bottom by
the biggest morons on earth and we all
have to be slightly grateful that there
wasn't a brain cell between them that
could have pulled this off because we
kept hearing how close it got and the
thing that kept it from crossing that
line from actually being successful was
the absolute idiocy of donald trump and
everyone he surrounded himself with
anybody with a half a brain was
stiff-armed as soon as they gave him any
pushback at all even the ones maybe
would have helped him pull this off
eastman being the only one even
marginally closed and the irony that he
favored
the eastman is sort of a soldier of the
law for him while rudy giuliani lynnwood
sydney powell and mike pillow were
gaggling about the oval office
just
scaring the living daylights out of any
of trump's legit lawyers and you can see
them they're all that's why they're all
testifying they're all trying to save
their law careers now haven't burger or
the
guy who's like
tell you know yelling at eastman like i
want to hear two words out of you
orderly transition you know
that
that's where all these guys are now the
ones that were giving him the truth what
the committee has to show
is that he knew he was lying and he
still does trump has to pretend
every single day that he buys the big
lie that he still believes it because if
he doesn't
he that's what makes them it puts him in
legal trouble in georgia right
right that's right he had that's his
only defenses that he genuinely believed
it and so the committee's doing a great
job i think of showing that everybody
paid to give him real advice was telling
him it was nonsense and he was shunning
them in search of someone who could give
him plausible idiocy in in lieu of
plausibility
so that he could make this argument
after the fact especially after the loss
i i agree with you i think the committee
is laying out that story very well and
the way they did kind of did the tick
tock with the arizona house speaker
today and when he spoke to his faith and
bran rather burger the same way uh
sterling the when they replayed that
that um
where he gave the press conference and
texas paul that right makes me want to
go to you is because
um a lot of times you know when when
you're speaking
i almost feel that energy um that that
sterling had that day through that
microphone when he said
stop your nonsense someone's gonna get
killed i i hear i hear the echoes of
texas paul um through that video what
was your take on some of this testimony
that we've seen in the second half
well you know i'll be honest with you
this hit very differently for me i i
left the other three hearings feeling
uh you know
positive i did i i thought okay we're
getting the information out here this
did nothing but pissed me off today i
mean every single person that spoke
i i lost respect for and i mean you look
at raffensberger everything he went
through and then you look at
i mean i just i was so furious listening
to what he was talking about that he put
up with
and and bowers and what he put up with
and then you see the interview with
raffesburger and he says will you vote
for trump
and he hems and haws about it
are you kidding me hell no
hell no i will not vote for trump he's a
piece of [ __ ]
rudy giuliani walking around
did you see his interview i mean when
when they when they interviewed him he
was the most little meat little
piece of garbage there was well i don't
know i i can't remember where i got my
i think maybe facebook i think maybe you
know i mean this guy is a complete piece
of [ __ ]
and people are still following these
people it's insane to me it is
absolutely insane to me you know yeah
one of the things that just really just
hit me you know b.j pacquiao resigned he
quit didn't tell anybody just practice
[ __ ] and left they had to figure out he
quit yeah they were surprised they were
surprised that day
they replaced him with bobby christine
now think about that they're in mid
steel
they go find somebody to put down in
georgia you know they had to think they
could rely on him christine took one
look at this and said
oh hell no
oh hell no
you are not dragging me down this road i
mean this was so
stupid eastman has to be the biggest
turd lawyer
to ever
ever come out of anybody's butt i mean
he is disgusting
and i'm so
angry at the end of this because it's
it's just
it all of it i mean you listen to the
president himself
you know the former president himself
and i just
want to vomit my mouth a little bit
every time i call him that but it's the
truth he is the former president of the
united states on the phone with the
secretary of state in georgia and you
know he is committing a crime
and he knows he's committing a crime he
is asking him
overturn this legal election for me do
it for me people will love you people
will be happy you do it for me and man
they'll love you right right [ __ ] these
people that those those are those are
nice ballots you have there it'd be
ashamed to something happen to him kind
of thing karen and nivolo i know i know
you have to jump very soon and i think
jessica does too so i want to i want to
go to you two again but karen first
karen speak to the georgia part and what
in in as few words as you can and i know
it takes a lot to explain this georgia
thing because it is so complicated but
tell us um from the legal standpoint
from a former prosecutor
tell us what what this testimony meant
today when everyone is is including paul
really pissed but they're really
clamoring to see if there's going to be
an indictment from georgia from this
grand jury that's been convened in
fulton county
look i think we i think we have to stop
calling it the big lie and start calling
it the big crime because
it's absolutely clear after today that
that's what happened in georgia and
i really if we really just focus on
the events of january 6
and
the find the votes find the ballots i
think they could easily bring an
indictment i think the problem is what
they're looking at is is it leads into
the weeks leading up to it and then the
weeks after and and you know you could
keep going and keep going and there's so
many different people and i just worry
that this investigation because there's
it's so involved and there are so many
people and so many different crimes that
could have been committed that they're
not going to pull the trigger uh in time
and they need to i mean they need to do
it now it's it's outrageous and they
should just keep it simple keep it
focused make it about the phone call and
and and sort of that piece of it and
they can always supersede the indictment
and bring a second indictment as they
continue their investigation and add
more charges and more people etc but
they need to they need to just that's
the cleanest crime to me
and it's it's so clear
right
real quick like because i have a
question about that karen because i my
theory is is that that is the biggest as
far as the election stuff that is the
biggest slam dunk case that's going
around because of the recording and all
that kind of stuff but that it is the
primary reason like i was said why trump
is pretending to believe this going
forward because that is really his only
way out if he believes there were a
hundred thousand votes out there even if
he's
an idiot for believing it the idea is he
thinks that he can squeak by and find
some reasonable doubt in in a jury or
any or in a judge throwing it out and
the idea that if he just sounds like he
buys it
that's enough because he was like all
i'm looking for is 11 000 votes come on
guys give me a break because there's 400
000 votes out there now we the testimony
today shows that any reasonable person
and this is where i i'm curious if they
can
you know kind of shoehorn this in there
any reasonable in
person
you know even still who is selling this
is doing it on purpose he's selling this
lie to cover his ass
to because of the georgia case
specifically that's what it seems like
to me i don't really advise it you know
i i've been reading the same kind of
legal pundits that you have and and
these very very serious white crawler
practitioners who i respect a lot are
saying that
honestly i don't buy it i don't think
you need that i don't think you need to
find that he you know think about it
like i think it's okay to
my husband cheated on me so i think it's
okay to shoot him you know i believe
that you know i believe that's okay i
agree
guess yeah they would prosecute me in
two seconds you know they would i mean
so my point is like i don't understand
why you know
for the record my husband
i love my husband her husband's fine
everyone here
but i say it because in my mind i do
think if that ever happened i'd be
justified you know but that doesn't mean
i can go out and do that right well i
think that applies to jan 6. that's my
point yes that's my point i don't
understand why all these why all these
exactly my point so that's what i was
going to agree with you how i don't
understand there's all these really
smart lawyers out there saying he had to
have what if he believes it that's a
defense and i'm kind of like i don't
understand why he had why that's a
defense i mean
i i think at a certain point he was told
so by so many people that it's not true
the courts and what 60 court cases all
the judges threw them all out all the
lawyers everyone around him said it's
not true at a certain point i i don't
care what's in his mind he's not allowed
to do it that's why it's not good of
course yeah it because bill barr
and everybody else who investigated this
told him
that there was nothing there and he
continued to repeat it it's not as if he
didn't have experts checking
so he didn't have to take
rothensberger's word on it he had so
many others
and he ignored his own people
so
willfully right willfully uh willful
ignorance of the law is not a defense
right yeah i i i ignore facts right
i think that's why he's pretending to
buy him sorry okay sorry i'm sorry go
ahead
i'm just saying that's that's why he
continues to do as many speeches where
he's claiming that it was true
that's his because he thinks that's his
wiggle room i don't necessarily i don't
think it's enough but i think it's 100
why he continues to sell the big lie as
hard as he does and regardless of the
fact that it's causing people to give
death threats to people that's the
that's that's the wanton disregard for
human life that he's doing in this to
cover his own ass he'll sell a lie
that endangers other people because
these lunatics in the maggot crowd are
threatening their lives
when he doesn't even buy it he's just
using this he thinks this is his only
way out sorry
yeah and that leads to my question i had
for karen and you have um
does this continuation
not make his pocket pardon that
everybody keeps assuming he gave himself
not worth wiping your butt with i mean
since he continued on to do this
i mean you cannot
pre-pardon a crime i mean he's continued
to crime since he left office well but
guess what guess what texas paul he can
only pardon federal crimes and georgia
is state so i don't care pocket pardon
or not he can still be prosecuted in
georgia so
there you go there you go
i do i have to hop off well i hate for
you to leave the midas media brady bunch
here
but uh we appreciate we appreciate you
joining us thank you very much aaron
yeah do you have to jump to do you have
to jump to jessica
i can stay for a couple more minutes
okay good i was i was going to jump to
you um um
you know this reminds me with the talk
of all this evidence that karen was
talking about piling up
and and jessica you can speak to this
because you you've seen this in action
with these people like they pile up so
many at this point within georgia like
crimes like like karen is saying he's
just crying at the crime it reminds me
of that part of jurassic park when jeff
goldblum's character walks up to this
big mound of stuff and he says wow
that's a big pile of [ __ ] like you you
can only imagine that some of these
prosecutors that that is almost the
intention is to create as much chaos as
and create as much of a mess as you
possibly can so it's hard to find what
the true mess is and how you can be
held accountable for it tell us jessica
because i know you've seen some of this
in action do is that really a strategy
that they use is to just as much chaos
as possible yeah chaos is their currency
for sure but that doesn't mean that we
can't
handle it that we can't through the
[ __ ] and and get to the heart of the
matter um as far as this this criminal
intent
i said this on the midas touch podcast
the first time i was ever on it there
are tapes from bob flop woodward from
early 2020
where
woodward says to trump
i think i understand you pretty well and
trump says back to him you don't
understand me you'll understand me after
the election
men's right
criminal intent this guy
he was planning on doing he knew he was
going to do whatever it took to keep
himself in power i don't care i i i
think that donald trump's a pretty bad
actor but as far as him
claiming time and time again that he
believed these lies that were being fed
to him by certain people while other
people were telling him the truth as
karen said that's no defense he knew the
truth he walked does not preclude him
from um from liability but
before i leave you guys i want to
skip to merrick garland i don't know if
you heard the news this morning but
merrick garland's taking a trip to
ukraine
to um
having to do with americans that have
been captured in ukraine
this is a this is a global situation
that we're dealing with what is
happening in russia is the consequence i
mean genocide
kidnapping of hundreds of thousands of
children to russia to be indoctrinated
and assimilated
this is the consequence of decades of
impunity for putin the chechnyans told
us the syrians told us he uh
with not enough pushback
these are the consequences of impunity
merit garland i hope you get to see it
right in front of your face
this is this
the stakes could not be higher this is
what we are facing we have to confront
this we have to end this impunity from
once and for all and be done with it i
agree
yeah
before i jump i just want to say you
guys have been sending me i've been
looking at the comments from so much
love
and support and
it means the world to me and i can't
thank you enough everyone go follow
jessica on on twitter it's at jessica
denson07 it's there on the screen
please follow jessica and maybe we can
get uh gabe can you throw it in the
comments there for us
twitter handle um go follow jessica and
go and go look at jessica's story
because it is a unique story in the
trump world where she is the only one
who's actually invalidated the trump nda
and she did it all by herself
she did it all by herself so thank you
jessica for joining us and i hope you
come back on thursday if you have time
to join us for more commentary i know
that thursday's gonna be the doj hearing
and for all the midas mighty out there
we will have it here on the midas media
network so follow the midas touch on
youtube it will start the gavel will go
down at 3 p.m eastern but we will start
our coverage an hour before
2 p.m eastern so jessica i hope you can
join us i'll get in contact with you to
see if we can um get you on that hearing
to you thank you very much for joining
us you're welcome
hi jessica
so here we are here we are the the brady
bunch
i'm just glad once now i'm just glad one
person left so i was no longer jan
don't you don't be so sure
tony
throwing the
it's absolutely true that we're seeing
uh you know outrage after outrage this
criminality
but one of the things that
is clear now
is that these threats that were
happening beforehand are going to happen
to these people going home tonight
every single one of those people
including uh
uh
shay and her mother and her grandmother
it isn't over for them right for anyone
and they took a great risk doing this
so i i take your point texas paul about
uh you know
why would they say that they vote for
trump again
these people
i don't excuse it don't don't get me
wrong i'm not justifying that it's time
that people found balls and said you
know enough
but the terror that they live under
is real and particularly for
eric greitens is is showing how to shoot
rhinos
we've got a video now to shoot rhinos
they're they're even tougher on their
own yep and these threats are real
they're going to be ongoing
so what i think is going to be
interesting is when we get to the
department of justice which is thursday
and i heard a little teaser uh and and i
i've got to leave you too but but i'll
say this
uh luke cheney is is basically
guiding us through this she's
she's doing an extraordinary job of
telling us what we just saw and what
we're about to see
and what we're about to see
if we don't get him is everything around
pat cipolloni but i don't think they're
done trying to get him i think that
negotiation is ongoing
and if we get the president's lawyer the
one who can tell us absolutely what was
in the room the other thing i don't know
if you've all seen it but this was
subpoenaed they've got the tapes whether
they get the witnesses they did on the
first day i don't know
but
uh for reasons that defy understanding
uh
like the proud boys the trump family
allowed a camera crew in
to shoot everything that they were doing
before
the results came in after the results
came in and then after uh before and
after january 6th this whole thing
is on film
yeah but yeah but david doesn't that but
doesn't that mean it's very on brands
because they're like we can get away
with anything who cares i mean he's the
guy who said i could shoot someone on
you know on fifth avenue and get away
with it
that that's that's great except this is
a situation where we're gonna see some
of his family members
turning on him again yep they're on
camera reacting in real time we're going
to see ivanka reacting in real time
pacing back and forth going how can i
get him to stop right well i think i
think they they announced this morning
that it has ivanka on the tape i believe
mike pence even has an interview
i believe mark meadows is shown on some
of this documentary documentary footage
um
it should be very interesting texas paul
what do you think about the documentary
i know i know you're excited to react to
any tape that comes that drops on uh
midas touch's uh youtube channel now i'm
excited to see the texas paul reacts to
some of this documentary footage what do
you make of it
they these have to be the dumbest
criminals i have ever seen in my life
hey let's go rob a bank you know what we
need here is we need a camera crew to
show just how good just get the news
station down here get it all live we're
good yeah but you know and not only that
let's let's have the cameras when we're
planning and then even afterwards let's
have the cameras just tell how we did it
i mean
on a character level you have to
understand something about trump this
came up when michael cohen was first
doing kind of his break breakaway in his
mia culpa was that
there in in these like hoa and arguments
he was having with tenants that michael
cohen would muscle these folks and trump
would eventually just bully them with
legal crap and try to drive them away
and all that kind of stuff there was one
point where cohen basically described
trump as believing that if you win in
court because you deserve to
that's not special
what really makes you a winner is if you
should have lost if you cheat the system
if you manage to win in spite of being
guilty and that that's a constant and
that's part of his ego
he actually needs that he needs to that
overcoming that i beat them you know in
spite of things and you know i'm i joke
all the time on my show about the fact
that i i think one of the reasons why he
knows where all the fraud is is because
he bought some and that a bunch of his
votes are just phony as hell yeah and he
knows it that's i mean that's that's why
they look at you know the only places
people are other blue states are like
yeah do a recount we give a [ __ ] you
know but in the red states they're like
don't look why because those are your
votes
oh there are dead people who voted and i
know it because i paid for them
four dead people they talked about right
on the fact that we're all republican
voters oh yeah well you go down to the
villages and that has the highest
concentration
of double voting of yeah every time they
find biting votes that weren't counted
or trump votes that shouldn't have been
or double voting or any of that [ __ ] my
one of my favorite stories and this is
what really points to the idiocy of the
entire mechanism and he does this he
thinks it's a dunk and he does it at all
his rallies where he talks about this
woman who you know presumably in georgia
or florida it changes whatever who knows
yes this woman who's a dignified woman
who loves her country and she wanted to
vote because she loves it so much and
she put on her best hat and she said
darling let's go vote and they go down
to the you know the voting booth and and
someone tells her someone already voted
in your name and she's just heartbroken
and she walks away and she lost her like
she didn't file a police report she'd
call the secretary of state's office she
didn't pitch a [ __ ] fit in the middle
of the goddamn thing like the the
concept is so absurd you're like and how
many of these three he tells three
different people none of them ever did
anything except leave you know why
because there were trump voters who
showed up to vote for him because he
told them to vote twice he said vote by
mail and go down there because they're
not going to do it and when they said
somebody already voted they went oh my
god that's
really i didn't run oh that's terrible
i'm gonna go make a phone call
because they knew they were trying to
commit a felony they actually got they
didn't realize that the elections are as
secure as they are right even rather
pointing out the the upc symbol that's
on every ballot that makes it unique
which is just that blows a huge hole in
the double voting and the bouncing that
votes off of a satellite sending them to
spain to be reconstituted
whatever and then sent back and then
they they raises the number of digital
votes so they have to print all these
chinese ballots with bandages all over
them and stack them in a room and don't
only pull them out if they if they
stop giving them ideas
all right guys we'll
see you uh
same time same place i think it's
thursday but again a little a little bit
later
some tweets even though you don't tweet
david
yeah
but there are going to be surprises
ahead count on that thank you david
thank you yeah see you guys see ya
texas paul um now now we're down to four
um we're much much more manageable
texas paul
this screen isn't big enough for the
right right right you're just big enough
for you sir right right
so so paul what do you think about the
um
the bamboo ballot space laser upc code i
actually um
how al did a great job of describing uh
what kind of crimes is next but i i want
to say that the actual testimony that
raptors burger and his chief operating
officer sterling gave today
like
even sterling's like i have some some
relatives of mine that i'm like i had to
explain this and explain this and even
attorneys who are smart and know what
the hell they're talking about i showed
him this and i showed him this and i
showed him this and then they're like
you know what i just know in my heart in
other words i don't give a damn what the
truth is i want him to win and that's
what i'm going to say i want no matter
what the truth is because damn the truth
and i think that's what gets you so
pissed off is that people are just
willing to lie just
to [ __ ] lie
amen that that's absolutely the truth
and what what's actually bad is
guys like bowers they're gone they're
not running the party anymore model runs
this party
and they are exactly that way it doesn't
matter what the what what's right or
wrong it's what i want
and and it's complete [ __ ] i mean
complete and utter [ __ ] and it makes
me want to know and i want to i'd hoped
to ask david this before he left because
you know he's from new york and one of
the stereotypes of new yorkers or new
yorkers and i
my experience that's [ __ ] new
yorkers are some of the nicest people
around they treat you really well when
you go up there they really do
but the other
stereotype about new yorkers is
absolutely true they do not take [ __ ]
off people
and what i want to know
is why
rudy giuliani can still walk around
unmolested now i'm not talking about
violence or anything like that but why
can't rudy giuliani who's running all
over the state of new york campaigning
for that freak of a son ahead i do not
know what went wrong with his genetics
but that kid is hard to look at
i mean snl did a great great cover of
him early when he was a kid so
oh my god is that is that the first
cousin kid well it looks it looks like
it looks like what's left over from the
vial that they used on air
yeah yeah
whatever was in the bottom they're like
i'll take it at discount it's already
they're like it's already in the 99 cent
bin
i would say texas paul for the record by
the way um they are uh quote-unquote
molesting him wherever he goes like he's
getting yelled at and he got yelled at
in that parade it's happened twice at
uh at andrews campaign events where he's
campaigning on behalf of his son and
people are asking him questions about
this and he's trying to shut it down he
ends up packing up and leaving he's
struggling [ __ ] so he doesn't really
know he does yeah
that's what's
i don't care if it's the proud boys i
don't care if it's the oath bastards i
don't care who the hell it is i don't
care if it's donald trump i don't care
if it's rudy giuliani or eastman these
people need to be pariahs that's yeah
right
yeah the shunning of them everybody in
my family knows
yeah a regular order it needs to be a
regular order that they're just that
that's not what you do no matter what
and that's that's where i do think the
impact of somebody like bowers or even
raffensberger will have an impact on the
rest of republicans because we are
watching them trying to rest this whole
party
back from the maggots and it's and
they're not i mean it's it's it's kind
of like coming back from being number
two in the third three person human
centipede you know what i mean you've
got damage on both ends and the
extraction process is going to be ugly
um
but you're right but they're going to be
scars for sure right they're definitely
going to be scars and just not your
digestive tract alone um but but that
that is genuinely that is having they're
never going to have an impact on us like
i'm not going to vote for a guy like
bowers or rapingsburger in my life
but
there is going to be sort of a strength
point that
they that i think baseline republicans
do find enticing about those people they
consider them to be religious
conservatives or or economic
conservatives or whatever their pick or
poison of conservatism is and they're
gonna that'll help them to align back
with that as opposed to this just
flagrant grotesque idiotic [ __ ]
grabbing nonsense that the party has
become and and that
the the lurkers that the nude level uh
you know militia types that have been
with us for a long time i mean they're
they're the ones that basically pulled
in timothy mcveigh they've always been
around
but but trump
more than anything gave those people a
sense that they belonged and that's i
think what
if i could either he passed out the
t-shirt he passed out the t-shirt all
right they they let the boogeyman out
you know you like the boogeyman out and
like he can't go back in right now and
they're right you see
back in the box right now afraid of the
maggot voters i think they're afraid of
the maggot murderers i think they're i
think a lot of these folks are tiptoeing
about this stuff they would all come out
brashly and say [ __ ] this guy except for
the fact that his followers are nut
cases many of them aren't there is a
huge difference between the people who
show up in front of uh you know
shay's door or or you know ruby's
joy door and the people who are showing
up in front of kavanaugh's door covering
themselves in blood or painting coat
hangers it's a totally different world
of protest and there's a lot of what
about ism like they showed up at the
door like you don't understand these
none of them tried to burst in none of
them were armed there's no open carry
leftist groups they i mean and and where
they are they're anarchists they don't
they're never going to vote democrat at
all anyway so that that is that's the
part and you can see
that's what bowers teared up about this
because he and his wife are old they're
not going to outrun these nut nicks yeah
right right yeah i mean like that one of
texas
yeah
let me let me just gabe i wanna i'm
gonna ask you a question here gabe yeah
yeah i think this goes to what he's
saying about um some of these
republicans because at the very end you
watched liz cheney like
you remember the carnival game where you
had the you know they had the clowns
that were up and you had the you had the
wooden balls and you're throwing the
wooden balls at the clowns that's what
it reminded me of at the very end that
liz cheney was doing like she was just
toss and she was saying names too she
did not she had no more [ __ ] to give
she's saying names at the very end bing
bing bing so what did you make of that
last you know effort to basically for
liz janey to call them out before
thursday's hearing because i think
you're going to hear a lot of these
names on thursday right that she was
trying to know
i think you know this is a is a tactic
by cheney to to drag everyone through
the streets you know it's like if i
can't bring you up in front of us to to
give hearing or to play depositions i'm
gonna publicly drag you and say who are
the people who are unwilling
to participate in a democracy and defend
it and your name is now on public record
and we will show again and again and
again
how all of you guys denied
wanting to actually tell us what
happened and what your role was or the
fact that you were just complicit in all
of it in silence right it's the cynical
mission the fact that you're not saying
anything
implies there's guilt to be had
yeah and these are the same i mean these
people are part of this this new crazy
maga crew who are willing like hal said
to go to people's houses like the
stories that we heard from from these
people today whether they were the
actual uh election representatives or
they were just the the uh the poll
workers themselves
was what was hard was difficult to hear
and disgusting to the extent that these
people because let's just call them what
they are these trump supporters are
domestic terrorists right they will do
whatever trump says and trump he loves
them all i mean he set it up to i mean
he continues to say i love
you you're the best show
you're amazing okay all right all right
all right but on january 6 when he was
told hey listen you need to say
something to get these [ __ ] off the
capitol he goes okay i'll send a couple
tweets and then he makes a video and he
says i love you all and it's like that's
not what you say but for trump yeah he
is an ego
maniac he loves the attention so if
you're killing for him if you're dying
for him then you are number one in his
book i mean he'll still cost you over
but he loves you right yeah oh no you're
like he loves cannon fodder almost more
than anybody because that's i mean look
at these people willing to throw
themselves on a fire for me and it's you
know in human history there's been
there's been you know hundreds of these
kind of leaders throughout the world in
tribal times to now it's not that
shocking the pole pots of the world
exist for a reason so does hitler so
does any of these mega maniacal benito
mussolini genghis khan whatever but
trump has this kind of like almost
pedestrian experience about it because
he's detached from the reality of these
losses he's not you know he has no i i
don't think he has a one-to-one vicious
streak
when it comes to maybe to men i think
maybe with women he has a one-to-one
vicious streak i think there's an
argument for that but when you look at
who he is he was sitting in the oval
office the stories that were coming out
about him sitting there watching
gleefully
what these people were doing to
themselves
for him they were they were all set to
turn themselves into murderers to get
themselves killed i mean a woman was
trampled to death in the tunnel i mean
the iron i mean at that story when they
talked about
well that's like that's i think you say
that's the ironic one isn't it yeah well
i mean
not quite the idea that they would
trample their own i mean that's what
lemmings do but the but the the most
ironic part was is that the people
giving her cpr then tried to drag her to
the very police that trump supporters
were trying to beat to death to save her
life and they tried
that's the other thing that the capitol
police that were blocking the tunnel
that they dragged her to
took her around the corner and tried to
continue you know cpr tried to save her
life
that that's
that's the difference between the
quality of human being that would storm
the capital on that day for that man
and the people who were there doing the
regular jobs and the police that were
protecting them while they did it well i
thought you were going to say that the
woman who did get trampled on was the
woman who was carrying the don't tread
don't tread on me flag right right
you cannot write this stuff it writes
itself
there was a story that there was a guy
who was attempting to steal something
off the wall and he had a taser and he
zapped his balls i don't know if that
would actually end up being true right
it's a complete comedy of errors with
these people i mean it sounds it sounds
about right oh yeah no i wouldn't
question it the ghost of kiev of balls
but it's still even if it's not true the
message is great
oh well we only got about five we only
got about five minutes left um so paul
give us give us your your final take
i'll go to hal and then gabe and then
i'll wrap it up give us your final take
two things one
how you act in public in texas is a big
thing you'll get a reaction you're from
your average texan if you act a fool
they
they get involved
and
the
we're also known as the non-voting state
that's over with there's been 30 years
of republican rule
there's a very palpable feeling people
are sick of this [ __ ] they have made
fools of themselves and people are like
that's it this is enough
the other thing that i've got to say is
i want to see the hashtag million
subscriber
challenge
i want to see that up there we are
working very hard we're going to we are
going to make the m we're going to make
mmn and the midas
media organization
one of the largest in the country right
now we're doing it right now
let's give a shout out here
i've got i've got a promo code to anyone
out there store.minustouch.com you can
use the promo code justice for 10 off so
start there and go hashtag you also get
uh eric hershman's bat if you use that
problem yeah that's true yeah the
justice bat with all of um with all of
eastman's blood on it how what's your
final thoughts um like i said i think uh
i stand by my um my statement earlier
that the reason why trump seems to think
he knows where all the fraud happened
almost by the county is because he
bought it um and uh that he you know
paid voters to show up and all the dead
people that voted were clearly trump uh
voters and i will stand by that legally
and uh i would also like to say
for the record that i in all honesty i i
wake up every day smiling during these
things as difficult as they are because
these people are morons and trump is not
going to run again he is going to bow
out at the last possible second because
he needs to save america money and he
can't afford to you to lose it it pays
his bills it is the only thing keeping
mar-a-lago afloat right now all the all
the
trump tower miami russian anchor baby
money has dried up there are no more
deutsche bank loans to be had the only
wellspring he has is donald trump team
king maker and if you notice that's the
brand they've been pushing he's picking
the people that will be the most mega
and then you watch
months before he has to declare whatever
the deadline is he's going to come up
with some sort of reason why he can't do
it and therefore he's going to be
picking people for the next five years
help us save america by uh we will vet i
personally donald trump will pick all of
the people that you need to vote for and
that's how you'll know that's that
that's that's for the record that's
right
well thank you for the uh thank you for
for the label of satire i appreciate it
i had to just legally for youtube yeah
right we don't we don't want them to get
we don't want to yeah there was a
massive there was massive voter fraud
and rigging but it was all by the trump
campaign and all the fake votes were
trump raised for the record nice name
it's it's complete satire right
totally
gabe what was your final thoughts uh
yeah i'm uh i'm excited to see where the
next i think even david indicated um
earlier in the beginning of the segment
that there's going to be well you
definitely have to follow up for what we
had earlier earlier last week that was
canceled uh but it sounds like there
might be seven hearings now which i'm
very interested to see how we play this
out you know i think with with the news
coming out about jenny thomas and
potentially january 6 saying you know
what screw it we're going to throw this
into the mix because now everyone knows
about it and everyone has questions so i
think these are some of the most
important things that need to be brought
up because if they're not brought up by
them the committee and also the machine
that they've created on social media
with twitter to share links and share
tweets and share videos and sound bites
then no one's gonna ask these questions
and if they don't do it then no one's
going to question
jenny thomas's role in different
organizations or clarence thomas's role
on the supreme court
right so i think that's something that
i'm most interested in and hopeful for
is that these newer uh or more recent
kind of um
uh news uh begin to brought up into the
actual record and i'm also you know i
don't know when i know there's a
documentary i don't know when that comes
out but if that becomes a real-time uh
fact check for all these people who have
already given depositions oh beautiful
yeah but but they had to have known that
that right right well i don't know i
mean like you you look at people like
roger stone and they give they have like
three documentaries happen at the same
time while he's you know trying to
do a coup
and he's going to continue to deny any
involvement in the actual coup itself so
oh stodger rhone star jeroen at the
heart of all of it possibly and and
that's another piece of news is we're
supposed to
uh figure out on thursday who the
connection between trump and the and the
proud boys and those keepers were we're
supposed to see who that back channel
was so that's going to be exciting for
them
right right
you know here here's what uh here's what
i'll tell you everyone out there
hit subscribe on the minus touch youtube
channel because you're going to want to
watch on thursday because we are going
to see these doj this is the hearing
that was postponed from last week so
this is when it's rescheduled for
thursday uh the gavel goes down at three
o'clock eastern but we will start our
coverage an hour early just like we have
every hearing at two o'clock eastern so
don't miss it on thursday and make sure
to go over to store.minustouch.com and
use the promo code justice for 10 off
all the merch
and also download these episodes on
apple spotify google
guys i i think i think
yeah thank you for joining us hal last
minute there i i watched you come in the
room and texas paul thank you very much
and thank you gabe um hey i want to say
yeah what a great job you guys do oh
dave tony thank you amazing job in
seeing everything wonderful job guys
don't get my ego
it might not fit in the brady bunch
that's right
diagram here so thank you thank you
fellas thanks guys thanks a lot have a
great one uh again everyone please
please subscribe to the midas touch
youtube channel we you we will be airing
on thursday
again we our coverage will start at two
o'clock eastern time an hour before the
hearing for commentary for the great
commentators that you've seen here on
the midas media network
we will bring more commentary during
that hearing on day five
until then good day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
do
[Music]
you